sobald es losgeht wie gesagt natürlich
schalten wir sofort ins plenum vorher
aber begrüße ich meine kollegin ines
trams aus unserem hauptstadtstudio die
debatte vor ort im bundestag beobachten
wird guten morgen ines was ist denn von
der heutigen regierungserklärung zu
erwarten wird es vor allem um corona um
eine impfpflicht um den erneuten mangel
an impfstoff gehen
ja patricia du hast es ja schon erwähnt
in den vergangenen wochen und im
koalitionsvertrag da war ganz viel von
aufbruch und mehr fortschritt wagen die
rede in seiner ersten großen rede vor
dem bundestag in dieser sogenannten
antritt
regierungserklärung hat olaf scholz
kanzler olaf scholz nun die möglichkeit
all das mit leben zu füllen ich denke er
wird sprechen natürlich von der
bekämpfung des klimawandels er wird
sprechen von sozialer gerechtigkeit
respekt war ja so ein thema das seinen
wahlkampf gekennzeichnet hat und er wird
natürlich sprechen von der bekämpfung
der pandemie abseits der inhalte denke
ich sollten wir schauen auf die
kommunikation oder scholz war bislang
als scholzomat bekannt als ein redner
der eher stoisch ruhig und ohne klare
kante seine worte vorgetragen hat wir
werden sehen ob sich das nun in der
neuen rolle als kanzler ändern wird
stichwort kommunikation das dürfte sich
vielleicht auch bei der neuen opposition
ändern cdu/csu sind ja nach 16 jahren
wieder in der opposition haben aber
bereits eine klage angekündigt gegen den
nachtragshaushalt der ampel wird auch
das heute thema werden wird der ton wohl
plötzlich ein anderer werden
ich denke ja die union ganz konkret die
cdu versucht sich in der neuen rolle als
opposition als größte oppositionspartei
zu finden und das mit scharfen tönen
oppositionsführer unions fraktionschef
ralph brinkhaus hat ja gestern schon die
politik der ampel als konturlos
bezeichnet als es im bundestag die
vergangenen wochen um das
infektionsschutzgesetz ging haben wir
scharfe worte gehört und du hast es
erwähnt schweres geschütz fährt die
union jetzt auf gegen den
nachtragshaushalt den finanzminister
christian lindner von der fdp vorgelegt
hat sie will eine normenkontrollklage in
karlsruhe anstrengen ich denke gerade
weil konkret die cdu noch auf
selbstfindungskurs ist sie sucht ja noch
einen neuen chef und auch eine neue
ausrichtung für die zukunft ich gerade
denke gerade deswegen
versucht sie als oppositionspartei in
diese rolle zu finden mit scharfen tönen
also noch hat die regierungserklärung
nicht begonnen deswegen reden wir hier
noch ein bisschen weiter für viel
sprengstoff sorgt er im augenblick der
umgang mit der afg das parlament tut
sich ja immer noch sehr schwer damit und
will verhindern dass der vorsitz des
innenausschusses an die afd geht wird
auch das heute hier thema sein ist das
zu erwarten
das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen es
geht ja darum dass die afg nun das
vorrecht weil die anderen parteien nicht
zugegriffen haben das vorrecht hat auf
den vorsitz des wichtigen
innenausschusses der innenausschuss der
hat einen direkten draht zu
geheimdiensten zu bka und dieser
innenausschuss wenn es denn so kommt
wenn der kandidat der afg heute
tatsächlich gewählt würde
einen vorsitzenden vorjahren
ich bedanke mich herzlich ich
entschuldige mich wir müssen jetzt rüber
gehen weil olaf scholz beginnt jetzt mit
seiner regierungserklärung herzlichen
dank
frau präsidentin für hat der abgeordnete
meine damen und herren bei
der bundestagswahl am 26 september hat
sich die mehrheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes für aufbruch und
fortschritt entschieden
der aufbruch soll gelingen werden noch
die ko-runde wir unsere ganze
aufmerksamkeit und kraft erfordert aber
umso wichtiger ist es jetzt nicht zu
zögern es gibt viel zu tun für
uns liegen große aufgaben und
entscheidende weichenstellung
weichenstellungen die wir jetzt
vornehmen weil wir jetzt den richtigen
zirkus in die zukunft einschlagen müssen
wir haben keine zeit zu verlieren
meine damen und herren das gilt
zuallererst für den kampf gegen die
korona pandemie die neue bundesregierung
übernimmt den staffelstab in
außergewöhnlich bedrückenden wochen
dezember das sind ohnehin die dunkelsten
und kürzesten tage des jahres das
schlägt aufs gemüt
aber dezember bedeutet sonst immer auch
adventszeit das ist die zeit in der wir
normalerweise stimmungsvolle
weihnachtsmärkte erleben gemütliche
stunden mit familie freunden und
bekannten am glühweinstand gesellige
weihnachtsfeiern im kreis von kollegen
und vereinskameraden
in diesem jahr ist das anders
jetzt schon zum zweiten mal die
bürgerinnen und bürger verfolgen abend
für abend auf ihren bildschirm die
entwicklung der korona pandemie viel zu
hohe infektionsraten erschöpfte
ärztinnen und krankenpfleger dramatische
verlegung von intensivpatienten per
flugzeug und hubschrauber
schlank vor impfzentren die sorge vor
der neuesten variante des virus
mir ist bewusst in diesen tagen fällt es
manchmal schwer den mut nicht zu
verlieren
ich weiß dass abstand halten und
glücklich seien sehr schlecht zusammen
passen dass viele unserer unter
einsamkeit leiten das endlich mal damit
schluss sein müsste dass es wieder los
gehen müsste das leben und die
unbeschwertheit
niemanden geht es richtig gut in diesen
zeiten mir nicht ihnen nicht den
bürgerinnen und bürgern nicht und viele
fragen sich geht das jetzt immer so
weiter oder wird es wieder besser heute
sage ich den bürgern und bürgern unseres
landes ja es wird wieder besser ja wir
werden den kampf gegen diese pandemie
mit der größten entschlossenheit führen
und ja wir werden diesen kampf gewinnen
wir werden die krise überwinden
und lage ist schwer aber die lösung
liegt auf der hand nach 20 monaten
pandemie wissen wir längst das virus mag
viele kontakte und verbreitet sich
darüber rasend schnell
darum war das oberste gebot dem letzten
langen winter kontakte zu reduzieren in
diesem winter sind wir etwas weiter
jeder kann und sollte sich regelmäßig
testen wir alle sollten unsere kontakte
weiter behutsam einschränken aber am
allerwichtigsten ist jeder kann und
sollte sich impfen lassen
darum geht es mir deshalb habe ich uns
ende november ein ehrgeiziges zwischen
ziel gesetzt ich möchte dass wir alle
zusammen in deutschland 30 millionen
impfdosen bis jahresende in die oberarme
kriegen als erste impfung als zweite
impfung und als booster empfohlen
so kriegen wir es hin die vierte welle
hinter uns zu lassen heute kann ich
sagen wir haben bereits 19 millionen
millionen impfungen erreicht wir sind
auf dem richtigen weg wenn wir mit aller
kraft weitermachen werden wir die 30
millionen bis jahresende auch erreichen
meine dringende bitte ist
wie wir bürgerinnen und bürger machen
sie alle mit dann schaffen wir die 30
millionen und dann sind wir am ende
dieses monats diesem einen
entscheidenden schritt vorangekommen
es ist mir wichtig dass wir es weiter
gemeinsam angehen dass wir uns weiter
unterhaken und so kroner besiegen
deshalb habe ich ein krisenstab
aufgebaut der aus dem kanzleramt heraus
jeden tag neu die lage bewertet und auch
handelt er wird von einem erfahrenen
general geleitet und wir haben experten
zusammen gerufen die die regierung
ständig beraten
deshalb erhöhen wir die kapazitäten der
impfzentren deutlich deshalb sind mobile
teams sind stadt und land unterwegs
deshalb beziehen wir jetzt auch
zahnarztpraxen und apotheken mit ein
deshalb sagen wir jetzt es ist sehr
wichtig dass alle dreifach geimpft sind
wir werden weiter kämpfen und noch mehr
boostern um die verbreitung des virus zu
erschweren
die pandemie die epidemie ist global
deshalb engagieren wir uns international
für impfstoffe in den armen ländern und
auch in europa werden wir gemeinsam
handeln schon morgen werden wir uns im
europäischen rat intensiv mit der kroner
lage in europa beschäftigen
wir werden alles tun was notwendig ist
es gibt dafür die bundesregierung keine
roten linien die bundesregierung wird
nicht einen einzigen augenblick runen
und wir werden jeden nur möglichen hebel
bewegen bis wir alle unser früheres
leben und alle unsere freiheiten
zurückbekommen haben
dass die notwendigen maßnahmen
eingeleitet werden das ist meine aufgabe
dafür trage die verantwortung und das
hat meine oberste priorität
und darum hier nochmals meine inständige
bitte an sie alle an alle bürgerinnen
und bürger helfen sie mit dieser aufgabe
zu bewältigen helfen sie uns allen
vermeidbares leid zu verhindern lassen
sie sich impfen schützen sie ihr leben
und das leben der anderen
der wahrheit dieser pandemie gehört aber
auch heute im dezember 2021 könnte jede
und jeder erwachsene in deutschland
längst zweifach geimpft sein
mindestens alle besonders gefährdeten
bürgern und bürger könnten gebucht sein
dann hätten wir die pandemie jetzt im
griff dann würden wir alle jetzt mit
unseren alten freiheiten und unseren
familien und freunden eine besinnliche
vorweihnachtszeit erlebten die kraft des
wissenschaftlichen fortschritts hätte
uns genau das ermöglicht und darum
verstehe ich auch den unmut vieler
bürgerinnen und bürger das sind ja die
die in der zeit der pandemie immer
vorsichtig gewesen sind die alles
richtig gemacht haben die sich an alle
regeln gehalten haben die doppelt und
dreifach geimpft sind sie haben alles
dafür getan dass wir unser früheres
leben und unsere frühere freiheit zurück
bekommen ihnen allen danke im namen der
gesamten bundesregierung von herzen
und danke ausdrücklich auch den
bundesländern ihren
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten für die enge und
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit in dieser
schwierigen zeit
allen verspreche ich diese
bundesregierung wird immer fest an ihrer
seite stehen sie wird immer an der seite
derjenigen in unserem land stehen die
sich solidarisch verhalten an der seite
derjenigen die mit ihrer vorsicht und
ihrer rücksichtnahme den zusammenhalt
unserer gesellschaft möglich machen
aber was es eben heute auch gibt in
deutschland das ist wirklichkeit
verleugnung das sind absurde
verschwörungs geschichten mutwillige
desinformation und
gewaltbereiten extremismus
um es klar zu sagen eine kleine
extremistische minderheit in unserem
land hat sich von unserer gesellschaft
unserer demokratie unserem gemeinwesen
und unserem staat abgewandt nicht nur
von wissenschaft rationalität und
vernunft
für die gesamte bundesregierung sage ich
wir haben respekt vor ernst gemeinden
einwenden wir hören zu wir suchen die
debatte wir sind offen für kritik und
widerspruch
wir geben auch den versuch nicht auf
bislang noch zurückhaltende davon zu
überzeugen dass sie sich doch impfen
lassen mit der kraft der fakten der
kraft der vernunft oder der kraft des
besseren arguments
aber genauso klar ist wir werden es uns
nicht gefallen lassen dass eine winzige
minderheit von enthemmten extremisten
versucht unserer gesamten gesellschaft
ihrem bild aufzutreten
diese winzigen minderheit der
hasserfüllten die mit fackel menschen
mit gewalt und morddrohungen uns alle an
greift werden wir mit allen mitteln
unseres demokratischen rechtsstaats
entgegentreten unsere demokratie ist
eine wehrhafte demokratie
viel ist ja zurzeit von der angeblichen
spaltung unserer gesellschaft die rede
dazu stelle ich fest unsere gesellschaft
ist nicht gespalten
überwältigende mehrheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger in unserem land verhält sich
solidarisch vernünftig und vorsichtig
die bundesregierung ist die regierung
dieser überwältigenden mehrheit sie ist
die regierung einer solidarischen
vernünftigen und vorsichtigen
bürgerinnen und bürger in unserem land
und sie ist ausdrücklich auch die
regierung derjenigen bürgerinnen und
bürger die noch zweifel haben oder
vielleicht ganz einfach noch nicht dazu
gekommen sind sich impfen zu lassen die
regierung ist die regierung der
bürgerinnen und bürger die sich an die
regeln halten und die umgekehrt erwarten
dass ihr staat sie in notlagen beschützt
und ihre freiheit sichern
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ausdrücklich danke ich und gerade an
dieser stelle der bisherigen
bundeskanzlerin frau dr merkel hat der
bundesrepublik deutschland 16 jahre lang
in eindrucksvoller weise als
bundeskanzlerin gedient jederzeit
orientiert an der sache und an den
tatsachen stets völlig uneitel und ohne
allüren immer mit mut und mit klugheit
mit pragmatismus und mit umsicht
in den wochen des regierungswechsels
mitten in dieser schwierigen zeit der
pandemie hat bundeskanzlerin merkel
alles nur mögliche getan um die
staffelübergabe an ihren nachfolger so
reibungslos wie nur irgend möglich zu
gestalten
die unaufgeregte
demokratische zivilität des übergangs
von der einen bundesregierung zur
nächsten bundesregierung wurde weltweit
mit viel bewunderung und respekt
aufgenommen
auch hier genauso wie für die
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit und
kollegialität in den vergangenen jahren
sage ich danke frau dr
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die neue bundesregierung wird unser land
in dieser wahlperiode zielstrebig auf
die kommenden jahrzehnte vorbereitet
ein modernes deutschland jederzeit auf
der höhe der herausforderungen unseres
jahrhunderts das ist das ziel das ist
die aufgabe die wir ab sofort anpacken
die bundesregierung die jetzt unter
meiner führung ihrer arbeit aufnimmt
wird eine fortschritts regierung sein
wir sind eine regierung des technischen
fortschritts weil wir nur mit
technischen fortschritt klimaneutral
werden können und weil deutschland und
europa nur so mithalten können im
globalen wettbewerb wir sind eine
regierung des sozialen fortschritts bei
respekt gerechtigkeit und lebenschancen
für alle eben keinen gegensatz zu sind
zu wirtschaftlicher stärke sondern deren
voraussetzung
und wir sind eine regierung des
gesellschaftlichen und des kulturellen
fortschritt die gesetz und recht an die
lebenswirklichkeit unseres vielfältigen
landes anpassen
die kraft des fortschritts jetzt in der
korona pandemie erleben wir sie doch
gerade wieder den m rna impfstoff haben
ursachen und öztürk hier bei uns in
deutschland erdacht und entwickelt nicht
zuletzt ihnen und ihren bahnbrechenden
impfstoff verdanken wir es dass diese
pandemie nicht noch um ein vielfaches
verheerender wirken konnte
es ist keine übertreibung
diese beiden forscher aus mainz am
millionen von menschen auf der ganzen
welt das leben gerettet ihr impfstoff
ist der beste beweis dafür dass kluger
fortschritt kluge innovation und kluge
modernisierung die welt besser machen
darum
darum setzen wir auf die kraft und auf
die möglichkeit des fortschritts und
zwar gerade jetzt in dieser zeit
wir brauchen fortschritt denn die
aufgaben die vor uns liegen sind
riesengroß
die klimakrise erfordert entschlossenes
systematisches und international
abgestimmtes vorgehen
die menschengemachte erderwärmung muss
gestoppt werden die pariser klimaziele
gelten
hinter uns liegen 250 jahre in denen
unser wohlstand auf dem verbrennen von
kohle öl und gas begründete jetzt liegen
vor uns etwa 23 jahre in denen wir aus
den fossilen brennstoffen aussteigen
müssen und aussteigen werden denn wir
haben uns verpflichtet bis 2045 muss
deutschland klimaneutral sein
damit biegt vor uns die größte
transformation unserer industrie und
ökonomie seit mindestens 100 jahren
hinzu kommen die herausforderung der
globalisierung und digitalisierung
beide prozesse haben die welt verändert
neue lebenschance und neuen wohlstand
gebracht auch bei uns in deutschland
aber zugleich macht die schiere dynamik
der entwicklung fielen hier in unserem
land auch sorgen sie fragen sich geht
das alles gut aus für mich für meine
familie für meine kinder in zehn zwanzig
dreißig jahren wird es in zukunft noch
gut bezahlte arbeit sichere renten und
ein gutes gesundheitssystem geben für
leute wie mich
was kommt dazu auf die stadt auf die
region in der ich lebe
das sind alles große herausforderung und
es sind nicht die einzigen
allen muss klar sein die vor uns
liegenden 20er jahre werden jahre der
veränderung der erneuerung und des
umbaus seien alle in unserem land wissen
dass wir brauchen diese erneuerung aber
zugleich wollen wir dass diese
erneuerung allen bürgerinnen und bürgern
in unserem land zugute kommt das ist
unser versprechen wir werden neue
sicherheit durch wandel schaffen und
werden sie für sicherheit im wandel
sorgen
natürlich reformen veränderung
fortschritt dass es niemals selbstzweck
mit der angeblichen notwendigkeit des
fortschritts runden in der vergangenheit
immer wieder auch problematische
entwicklungen gegründet die ökologischen
krisen mit denen wir es heute weltweit
zu tun haben sind nicht zuletzt auch
folgen früherer vorstellung von
fortschritt manche entwicklung wurden zu
ihrer zeit als großer fortschritt
gefeiert im rückblick sehen wir sie aber
kritisch denken wir an die vorstellung
von der autogerechten stadt denken wir
an die atomenergie oder bestimmte form
der industriellen landwirtschaft
aber damit ist doch nicht die idee des
fortschritts selbst widerlegt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert brauchen
wir nicht weniger fortschritt sondern
mehr fortschritt
aber wir auch einen besseren fortschritt
wir brauchen kluge fortschritt
fortschritt für eine bessere welt für
ein besseres land für eine bessere
gesellschaft für mehr freiheit für jede
einzelne bürgerin und jedem einzelnen
bürger das ist der fortschritt den wir
wollen
diesen weg des fortschritts der
erneuerung und transformation wird die
neue bundesregierung auf allen ebenen
konsequent einschlagen unser wohlstand
unsere
lebensqualität und die arbeitsplätze des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts hängen
davon ab dass uns diese modernisierung
gelingt und darum fangen wir jetzt an
dabei wissen wir veränderungen fällt
schwer aufbruch ist nicht einfach
im internationalen vergleich ist
deutschland ein stark ist ein
erfolgreiches seien sehr wohlhabendes
land gute ideen hochwertige produkte und
verfahren haben den aufstieg unseres
landes zu einer der weltweit führenden
industrienationen begründet made in
germany das ist seit über 100 jahren
weltweit ein gütesiegel und gerade darum
ist die versuchung manchmal ein bisschen
groß weiter auf die schon vorhandenen
erfolgsrezepte zu setzen es ist ja immer
verlockend bislang erfolgreiches einfach
weiterzumachen
kaiser wilhelm dem zweiten wird das
zitat zugeschrieben
ich glaube an das pferd das automobil
ist eine vorübergehende erscheinung
das war ein irrtum
hätte sich diese sichtweise seinerzeit
durchgesetzt dann wäre deutschland heute
ein anderes land ein engeres land ein
rückständiges land
darum werden wir in deutschland neue
wege einschlagen auch da wo das
bestehende auf den ersten blick noch oft
gut funktioniert heute ist deutschland
ein starkes land aber gerade darum muss
uns jetzt der aufbruch gelingen gerade
jetzt müssen wir handeln darum will die
regierung mehr fortschritt war
ja es ist ein wagnis von bewährten
rezepten abzukehren es ist ein wagnis
aufzubrechen und den weg der veränderung
einzuschlagen aber dieses wagnis müssen
wir eingehen denn waidhaus waghalsiger
als aufbruch und fortschritt deren jetzt
stillstand und weiter so es geht nicht
wenig um weniger als die
lebensbedingungen heutiger und
zukünftiger generationen auf der erde es
geht um den zukunft von wohlstand und
arbeitsplätzen hier bei uns in
deutschland darum müssen wir den
aufbruch hinbekommen und das werden wir
auch wenn wir uns auf unsere stärken
konzentrieren wenn wir auf unseren
erfolgen aufkommen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
eine der großen stärken unseres landes
und auch eine der wichtigsten
voraussetzungen unseres wirtschaftlichen
erfolgs war immer unser
gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt nicht
erst in der korona pandemie spüren nein
erleben viele bürgerinnen und bürger
dieser innere zusammenhalt diese
gesellschaftliche solidarität ist
gefährdet
ein leitbild das leitbild der neuen
bundesregierung in dieser lage ist eine
gesellschaft des respekts
respekt anerkennung acht dort das
bedeutet dass wir uns bei aller
verschiedenheit gegenseitig als gleiche
unter gleichen wahnsinnigen respekt
heißt niemand schaut auf andere herab
weil er oder sie sich für stärker hält
für gebildete für reiche damit allein
wären wir schon ein großes stück weiter
denn viele der verletzungen und
kränkungen unserer gesellschaft haben
ihre ursache darin dass sich bürgerinnen
und bürger nicht genügend wahrgenommen
führen aber wenn uns die korona pandemie
eines gelehrt hat dann doch dies es gibt
keine höherwertigen und minderwertigen
tätigkeiten in unserem land
kassiererin oder krankenpfleger
reinigungskräfte paketboten oder bahn
schaffnerin sie alle leisten ihren
unverzichtbaren beitrag zu unserem
gemeinwesen hat mittels
administrative akademische oder
künstlerische tätigkeit sind keine
besseren oder würdigeren tätigkeiten sie
sind andere tätigkeiten auch sie
verdienen natürlich respekt
mehr augenhöhe und weniger herablassung
das ist das eine wenn wir eine
gesellschaft des respekts wollen das
andere ist eine tatkräftige politik für
mehr respekt und das wird die
bundesregierung leisten denn applaus für
krankenpflegerin oder das trinkgeld für
den paketboten das ist gut und richtig
aber das reicht nicht wir brauchen eine
aktive politik die respekt ermöglicht
respekt bewahrt und immer wieder
erneuert und dabei geht es um harte
materielle soziale und ökonomische
fragen
niedrige löhne für anstrengende arbeit
prekäre beschäftigung ohne tarifvertrag
armut im alter
wohnungsmangel und explodierende mieten
fehlende lebensperspektive in manchen
ländlichen regionen nicht zuletzt in
ostdeutschland in solchen mißständen
kommt aus sicht der betroffenen oft
fehlender respekt vor ihrer leistung und
ihrer anstrengung zum ausdruck
missstände wie diese sind deshalb gift
für unseren zusammenhalt darum werden
wir sie beheben und wir fangen jetzt
damit an
war es auch zu jeder politik des
respekts gehört dass sie sich konsequent
gegen rassismus sexismus und jede andere
diskriminierung richtet hier werden wir
nicht nachlassen auch vom weiteren
fortschritt in diesen fragen hängt der
zusammenhalt unserer gesellschaft
und gerade auch im kontext unserer
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger mit nicht
deutschen wurzeln ist der begriff des
respekts besonders wichtig millionen von
ihnen sind hier geboren viele familien
leben schon seit generationen in
deutschland ihre eltern und großeltern
haben als sogenannte gastarbeiter massiv
zum aufbauen wohlstand unseres landes
beigetragen
wir sprechen hier von fast einem viertel
unserer bevölkerung sie haben anspruch
auf volle teilhabe am gesellschaftlichen
leben in diesem land
wir sind ein einwanderungsland um ein
begriff unseres bundespräsidenten
aufzugreifen ein land mit
migrationshintergrund aber
wir müssen ein noch besseres
integrationsland werden dafür fühle ich
mich verantworten
und alle die sich hier bei uns in
deutschland für ihre persönliche zukunft
anstrengen haben mich und die
bundesregierung auf ihrer seite
meine damen und herren diese konkreten
aufgaben mit einer politik des respekts
anzugehen das ist auch wichtig um das
soziale vertrauen in unseren land zu
stärken das vertrauen in die demokratie
und ihre institution
die bürgerinnen und bürger gerade
besonders
schutzbedürftigen unter ihnen erwarten
von ihrem staat dass er sie so gut wie
möglich vor krisen und deren folgen
schützt und im staat dies nicht gelungen
ist dann muss er für die zukunft lernen
das wird eine der großen politischen
aufgaben der nächsten jahre
und dazu gehört auch dass wir das was
wir globalisierung nennen so angehen
dass diese entwicklung unserer
gesellschaft nicht im lager spaltet wenn
wir dem gefährlichen trend der
renationalisierung etwas entgegensetzen
wollen dann darf nicht der eindruck
entstehen die globalisierung seit der
demokratischen kontrolle entglitten
darin wird die bundesregierung konkrete
politische initiativen vorantreiben die
deutlich machen wir können eine
gerechtere globalisierung durchsetzen am
projekt an der internationalen
mindestbesteuerung zb beteiligen sich
inzwischen 137 staaten das ist nicht nur
aus fiskalischen gründen ein wichtiges
anderen sondern gerade auch deshalb weil
es die gerechtigkeit und das vertrauen
in die demokratie stärkt
um es klar zu sagen die frage nach den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt ist
keine frage der wir uns erst dann zu
wenden müssten wenn wir irgendwann alle
anderen großen probleme gelöst haben von
der pandemie über die industrielle
transformationen bis zur
klimaneutralität es ist genau umgekehrt
die großen probleme unserer zeit werden
wir überhaupt nur dann bewältigen wenn
wir uns unterwegs nicht der zusammenhalt
unserer gesellschaft abhanden kommt
soziales vertrauen und sozialer
zusammenhalt zu organisieren das ist die
voraussetzung schlechthin dafür dass
deutschland in diesem jahrhundert eine
gute zukunft haben wird gelingen wird
uns das nur mit einer politik des
respekts einer politik die immer alle
bürgerinnen und bürger im blick behält
meine damen und herren in der tat wir
haben große aufgaben vor uns deutschland
muss und deutschland wird in den 2020er
jahren den aufbruch hin zu einer
klimaneutralen und digitalisierten
gesellschaft vollziehen die
bundesregierung wird die arbeit
aufnehmen damit deutschland gestärkt aus
diesem wandel hervorgeht damit das leben
der bürgerinnen und bürger besser wird
damit unsere wirtschaft prosperiert und
viele gut bezahlte neue arbeitsplätze
entstehen
die kommenden vier jahre werden wir auch
dafür nutzen deutschland strukturell fit
zu machen für die welt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts damit die
transformation gelingt brauchen wir eine
moderne verwaltung die den wandel voran
treibt statt ihn zu verzögern es geht um
technische und gesellschaftliche
innovationen es geht um
milliardenschwere investitionen neue
wohnung schienenwege ladesäulen
offshore-windparks pv-anlagen stromnetze
und vieles vieles mehr es geht darum die
fundamente für ein neues technologisches
zeitalter zulegen von der wasserstoff
pipeline über die dezentrale
stromversorgung bis hin zur elektro
ladesäule darum werden wir in
jahrzehnten der zukunftsinvestitionen
einläuten
der größte teil dieser investition wird
privatwirtschaftlich erbracht werden die
regierung wird sicherstellen dass die
rahmenbedingungen dafür stimmen wir
werden langfristig verlässliche politik
machen die im dialog mit unternehmen und
beschäftigten steht und klare
orientierung bietet wo es möglich ist
werden wir marktmechanismen nutzen etwa
einen starken europäischen
emissionshandel wo es nötig ist werden
wir das ordnungsrecht einsetzen zb bei
der klimafreundlichkeit von gebäuden und
wo es sinnvoll ist werden wir
förderprogramme schaffen um anfangs
höhere preise neuer technologien
auszugleichen und investitionen in
klimafreundliche technologie zu
unterstützen
deshalb werden wir eine super
abschreibung für klimaschutz und
digitale wirtschaftsgüter schaffen
diese investitions prämie wird es den
jahren 22 und 23 möglich machen einen
anteil der kosten der im jeweiligen jahr
angeschafften oder hergestellten
wirtschaftsgüter des anlagevermögens vom
steuerlichen gewinn abzuziehen und
zusätzlich werden diese wirtschaftsgüter
entsprechend ihrer nutzungsdauer linear
abgeschrieben von dieser super
abschreibung profitieren somit alle die
in besonderer weise in klimaschutz und
digitalisierung investieren
außerdem werden wir die in der korona
krise ausgeweitete möglichkeit
verlängern und erweitern das
unternehmerische verluste bei der
berechnung von steuerzahlen rück rücken
stärker berücksichtigt werden können
auch das schafft finanziellen spielraum
für unternehmen
ein wichtiger treiber für innovationen
und investitionen sind start ups wir
werden das potenzial das von solchen
innovativen unternehmens ideen für die
transformation ausgeht stärker nutzen
und unser land zum führenden start-up
standort in deutschland machen
auch die rolle der kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau bei der finanzierung von
start ups werden wir ausbauen und wir
verbessern die steuerlichen bedingungen
wenn mitarbeiter sich an ihren
unternehmen beteiligen gerade für
startups ist es eine wichtige maßnahme
damit die transformation unseres landes
gelingt wird die bundesregierung in den
kommenden vier jahren viele milliarden
euro einsetzen müssen dafür werden wir
den verfassungsgemäß zulässigen
spielraum nutzen ein wichtiger kern für
diese zukunftsinvestition ist der
energie- und klimafonds den wir zu einem
klima und transformation sfo ausweiten
und besser ausstatten werden
zugleich kommt es jetzt darauf an dass
wir genau überprüfen auf welche ausgaben
wir natürlich verzichten können und wo
dem staat einnahmen vorenthalten werden
darum wird die bundesregierung den kampf
gegen steuerhinterziehung und steuer
umgehen weiter voranbringen und weltweit
eine vorreiterrolle übernehmen
wir raten steuerumgehung weiter
erschweren diejenigen die für sich
selbst und ihre kundinnen und kunden
steuertricks entwickeln und vermarkten
müssen diese den zuständigen behörden
jetzt auch für rein nationale fälle
melden so kann dann der gesetzgeber
schnell auf neue umgehungsmöglichkeiten
reagieren deshalb werden wir die bereits
eingeführte mitteilungspflicht für
grenzüberschreitende steuergestaltung
auch auf nationale steuergestaltung für
unternehmen mit einem umsatz von mehr
als zehn millionen euro ausweiten
trotzdem insgesamt gilt für die
haushaltspolitik der kommenden jahre
nicht alles was wünschenswert ist wird
sofort machbar sein die notwendigen
maßnahmen zur bewältigung der
transformation können und werden wir
aber sicher finanzieren
und auch das ist nicht neue finanz
spielräume entstehen durch wachstum
wachstum wiederum ist das ergebnis
kluger investitionen und darum war und
ist es richtig nicht gegen die krise
anzusparen sondern auch breite hilfen
und hohe investitionen möglich zu machen
so dass wir aus der krise heraus wachsen
meine damen und herren für den erfolg
der transformation ist die höhe der
eingesetzten mittel aber nur die eine
seite
erfolgreich wird die transformation nur
sein wenn investition deutlich schneller
wirksam werden
darum werden wir innerhalb des ersten
jahres dieser bundesregierung ein
umfassendes paket zur planungs und
genehmigungsbeschluss vorlegen unser
ziel ist die dauer der verfahren zu
halbieren dafür werden wir die
personelle und technische ausstattung
der behörden und gerichte ausbauen das
wollen wir mit einem
beschleunigungsprogramm mit den ländern
angehen
große und besonders bedeutsamen
infrastrukturmaßnahmen also etwa
wichtige bahnstrecken oder stromtrassen
werden wir per gesetz auf den weg
bringen und wir werden regelungen
treffen die das verhältnis von klima und
artenschutz klären
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
klimaschutz wird in dieser
bundesregierung zu einer zentralen
querschnittsaufgabe und wir wollen uns
gemeinsam daran messen lassen wie
erfolgreich wird diese aufgabe lösen
schon im kommenden jahr werden wir ein
umfassendes sofortprogramm beschließen
dass unsere anstrengung treibhausgase zu
verringern quer durch alle sektoren
verstärkt
wir werden die europäische kommission
aktiv dabei unterstützen ihr klimapaket
fifty five zu unter zu verwirklichen und
wir wollen gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen partnern die europäische
und die internationale klimapolitik
voranbringen wir werden noch unsere
internationalen bemühungen für den
klimaschutz erhöhen wir sind dem pariser
klima abkommen verpflichtet und werden
zu seinem erfolg beitragen
gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig werden wir zusammen mit
unseren partnern die gründung eines
offenen klima clubs voranbringen der
sich auf gemeinsame standards
verständigt und deutsche unternehmen im
internationalen wettbewerb vorgaben
dicke geschützt
meine damen und herren der wohlstand
unseres landes hängt an unserer
fähigkeit die infrastrukturen für das
klimaneutrale zeitalter aufzubauen bei
der energieversorgung wird das besonders
deutlich
im kommenden jahr beenden wir das
zeitalter der atomkraft in deutschland
nach jahrzehnten des gesellschaftlichen
konflikts
gleichzeitig arbeiten wir am zügigen
ausstieg aus der kohleverstromung
idealerweise schon im jahre 2030 es hat
ja um das wort idealerweise debatten
gegeben es bedeutet aber ganz einfach
voraussetzung eines vorgezogenen
ausstiegs ist versorgungssicherheit
voraussetzung ist dass wir einen großen
teil unseres strombedarfs aus windkraft
und photovoltaik decken können dass wir
neue gaskraftwerke bauen und diese
baldmöglichst mit wasserstoff betreiben
können meine damen und herren heute
liegt der strombedarf in deutschland bei
560 terawattstunden wir rechnen damit
dass er im jahr 2030 zwischen 680 bis
750 terawattstunden betragen wird wir
müssen also mindestens
120 terawatt stunden zusätzlich decken
das ist ungefähr der heutige strombedarf
der niederlande ein land mit fast 18
millionen einwohnern
80 prozent unseres strombedarfs sollen
bis 2010 erneut waren energieträgern
gedeckt werden das bedeutet wir müssen
die produktion von erneuerbaren strom
bis 230 mehr als verdoppeln ja
das ist eine gigantische aufgabe
aber ich bin der festen überzeugung
das wird uns gelingen
auf die grundlagen haben wir uns
verständigt schon im kommenden jahr
werden wir würden und hemmnisse
beseitigen und es sollen zwei prozent
der fläche in deutschland für die
windkraft reserviert werden
photovoltaik module sollen auf deutschen
dächern zur regel werden bei
gewerblichen neubauten werden sie
verbindlich vorgeschrieben wir werden
den ausbau unserer offshore wind
kapazitäten voranbringt und mit unseren
nordsee partnern stärker kooperieren wir
fördern den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien aber wir fordern auch auf dauer
müssen sich die erneuerbaren energien
auf dem markt finanzieren darum werden
wir den voerder freien zubau stärken
wenn der kohleausstieg vollendet ist
muss auch die förderung der erneuerbaren
energien auslaufen
frau präsidentin ein zentraler pfeiler
unser klima politik ist die
verkehrswende
dass die bürger nur bürger heute
deutlich mobiler sind als vor 30 50 oder
100 jahren ist eine große errungenschaft
mobilität erweitert den horizont
ermöglicht teilhabe begegnung und
lebenschancen
wir werden in den kommenden jahren dafür
sorgen dass mobilität einfacher
komfortabler und klimafreundlicher wird
und dabei für alle bezahlbar bleibt
unser schwerpunkt wird auf dem ausbau
der schiene liegen wir werden die
großstädte besser an den fernverkehr
anbinden und das europäische nachtzug
netz ausbauen wir werden die bahn wieder
stärker im ländlichen raum verankern und
wo es sinnvoll ist stillgelegte trassen
reaktivieren
wir wollen den anteil des
schienengüterverkehrs bis 230 deutlich
erhöhen und die fahrgastzahlen
personenverkehr deutlich steigern dafür
werden wir den kommenden jahren die
schienenwege ausbauen und mit digitaler
technik ausstatten und wir werden das
finanzielle engagement des bundes für
den nahverkehr noch einmal steigern mit
den ländern und kommunen wird werden
ausbauen modernisierungs pakt für einen
besseren öpnv ausschließen
gleichzeitig wollen wir die
nutzerfreundlichkeit über die
verschiedenen verkehrsverbünden hinweg
erhöhen zum beispiel durch gemeinsame
qualitätsstandards oder eine klarere
tarifstruktur zugleich wissen wir für
viele bürgerinnen und bürger wird das
auto weiter und verzichtbar sein viele
fahren gern mit dem auto und das soll
auch so bleiben
aber die antriebe müssen klimafreundlich
werden nach mageren jahren hat sich die
elektromobilität zu einer
erfolgsgeschichte entwickelt wir werden
dafür sorgen dass sie weiter tempo
aufnimmt
viele hersteller haben ehrgeizige pläne
ihre produktion auf klimafreundliche
antriebe umzustellen mit dem ausbau der
heimischen batteriezellen fertigung
werden wir dafür sorgen dass ein hoher
teil der wertschöpfung rund ums
automobil in deutschland bleibt wir
werden die staatliche förderung für 2022
fortschreiben und danach schrittweise
abbauen und gerade im bereich der plug
in den brite stärker an der elektrischen
fahrleistung ausrichten unser ziel ist
dass im jahre 2030 in deutschland 15
millionen elektroautos unterwegs sind
der schlüssel hierfür liegt in der
ladeinfrastruktur
laden muss so einfach werden die tanken
das angebot an ladesäulen muss den
bedarf zunächst vorausgehen die
förderung für den ausbau der
ladeinfrastruktur werden wir effektiver
und effizienter ausgestalten hemmnisse
in genehmigungsprozessen bei
netzinfrastrukturen netzanschluss
bedingungen werden wir abbauen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
in staat und gesellschaft streben wir
einen digitalen aufbruch an dazu gehört
zunächst für alle wichtig und erfahrbar
die digitale infrastruktur
unser ziel ist die flächendeckende
versorgung mit glasfaser und dem
neuesten mobilfunkstandard wir werden
besonders dort investieren wo der
nachholbedarf am größten ist um
funklöcher zu schließen deutschland muss
als technologiestandort wieder an die
spitze kommt
darum werden wir investitionen im
künstlichen intelligenz und quanten
technologien im cyber sicherheit robotik
und weitere zukunftstechnologien stärken
und wir wollen auch die
halbleiterproduktion ausbauen
auch die digitalisierung der verwaltung
werden wir entschieden vorantreiben von
den einheitlichen digitalen lösungen für
bund und länder arbeiten
in europa werden wir uns dafür einsetzen
dass die datenschutzbestimmungen der
datenschutz grund verordnung besser und
einheitlicher durchgesetzt werden wir
brauchen aber auch ambitioniertere
regelungen für einen fairen wettbewerb
in der digitalwirtschaft das
bundeskartellamt werden wir im umgang
mit plattform deshalb stärken
präsidentin meine damen und herren lösen
werden wir alle dieser großen aufgaben
nur wenn alle bürgerinnen und bürger in
deutschland klar kommen können und das
hat voraussetzung
eine davon ist die anhebung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro
das soll im laufe des kommenden jahres
geschehen der bundesarbeitsminister wird
dafür zeitnah einen gesetzentwurf auf
den weg bringen
der gesetzliche mindestlohn wurde schon
vor sechs jahren eingeführt lag zu
beginn bei 8 euro 50 die erfahrungen
sind positiv viele arbeitnehmer und
arbeitnehmer haben profitiert die
warnung vor geschäftsaufgaben und
entlassungen waren unbegründet
das mindestlohngesetz sieht die
regelmäßige anpassung durch eine
unabhängige kommission vor diese
regelung werden wir beibehalten
und doch werden wir einen einmaligen
anpassungsschritte des gesetzgebers
vornehmen das ist in einem reichen
wirtschaftlich starken land die unsere
möglich und das ist auch nötig meine
damen und herren
bis zu zehn millionen erwerbstätige
werden davon profitieren und ihren
lebensunterhalt besser bestreiten können
es ist der ganz konkrete ausdruck einer
politik des respekts dasselbe gilt für
die gleichstellung von frauen und
männern die muss in diesem jahrzehnt in
unserem land endlich realität werden und
nicht erst in irgend einer fernen
zukunft
wirkliche leistung bedeutet über den
gleichen einfluss die gleiche macht und
die gleichen möglichkeiten zu verfügen
gleichstellung bedeutet auch für gleiche
arbeit muss gleicher lohn gezahlt werden
dazu werden wir die möglichkeiten
ausbauen die das entgelt
transparenzgesetz bietet meine damen und
herren
respekt vor leistung heißt auch respekt
vor lebensleistung das bedeutet im alter
nach einem langen berufsleben eine
angemessene rente zu erhalten wir wissen
um die herausforderungen einer älter
werdenden gesellschaft ein hohes niveau
sozialer sicherheit zu garantieren und
zugleich das system bezahlbar zu halten
darum sichern wir das mindest
rentenniveau bei 48 prozent
wir sehen noch keine weitere anhebung
der regelaltersgrenze vor
und zugleich werden wir den
nachholfaktor wieder gelten lassen und
bauen denn die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung eine teilweise
kapitaldeckung ein
aus dem haushalt werden der
rentenversicherung kommen ja zunächst
zehn milliarden euro zugeführt die
rentabel angelegt werden können und als
demokrat pires erwitter dienen wichtig
ist uns auch dass möglichst viele
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmer anspruch
auf eine betriebsrente haben und eine
weitere aufgabe in dieser
legislaturperiode wird es seinen zeiten
der anhaltenden niedrigzinsen bessere
angebote in der dritten säule der
privaten altersvorsorge zu entwickeln
gerade für solche die staatlich
gefördert werden
alle selbstständigen sofern sie nicht in
versorgungswerken abgesichert sind oder
eine entsprechende private
altersvorsorge aufbauen werden in
zukunft gesetzlich versichert sein damit
einer etwaigen armut im alter vorgebeugt
wird
meine damen und herren auch unser
gesundheitsversorgung und unser
pflegesystem müssen den
herausforderungen der zukunft gerecht
werden was besser werden muss haben wir
gerade auch in der pandemie erlebt wir
brauchen heimische kapazitäten der
medizinischen produktion um nicht wieder
in abhängigkeit zu geraten
wir werden den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst besser ausstatten und
das medizinische personal
konkurrenzfähiger bezahlen
wir werden die chancen der
digitalisierung auch im
gesundheitssystem heben wir werden die
ambulante versorgung verbessern die
krankenhausplanung und finanzierung
reformieren
meine damen und herren
die pflegekräfte die frauen und männer
in der pflege haben großartiges
geleistet oft über das erträgliche
hinaus ihnen gilt unser dank
wir haben deshalb ein pflege bonus
vereinbart und werden die
steuerbefreiung anheben doch wir wissen
dass das noch keine strukturelle lösung
ist darum werden wir die
arbeitsbedingungen der pflegekräfte
verbessern indem wir eine bessere
personalausstattung in krankenhäusern
möglich machen werden
wichtig ist auch dass wir die lücke
zwischen den löhnen der kranken und
altenpflege schließen denn bürgern und
bürger pflegebedürftig werden ist das
für sie und ihre angehörigen oft
finanziell überfordern darum werden wir
die eigenanteile der kosten pflege ein
begrenzen
und meine damen und herren wir werden
prüfen wie eine freiwillig wählbare
pflege vollversicherung im alltag alle
pflegekosten und die zusätzlich anfangen
aufkommen kann
meine damen und herren dreh und
angelpunkt für die zukunft der sozialen
sicherung bleibt der arbeitsmarkt
darum ist es wichtig dass wir ein
weiterhin hohes und möglichst noch
steigen das beschäftigungsniveau in
deutschland haben am besten mit
sozialpartnerschaft mit tarifbindung und
mitbestimmung gerade in zeiten des
wandels brauchen wir starke
gewerkschaften und starke
arbeitgeberverbänden
ein hohes beschäftigungsniveau ist auch
aus gesellschaftlichen und
wirtschaftlichen gründen nötig wir
werden die situation in der pflege
nachhaltig und
nur dann verbessern wenn mehr
pflegekräfte dort tätig sein können wir
werden viele unserer vorhaben von
wohnungsbau bis zur energiewende nur
dann hinbekommen wenn ausreichend
qualifizierte fachkräfte im einsatz sind
für eine bessere pflege für den bau von
wohnungen für die industrielle
transformation für innovative
unternehmen überall brauchen wir
qualifizierte arbeitskräfte
das ist im übrigen ein fast schon
symbolhaftes projekt der neuen
fortschritts regierung weil wir hier
wirtschaftliche ziele mit sozialen und
gesellschaftspolitischen zielen
verbinden und wir müssen daher auch für
gute aus und weiterbildung klagen
dass es mir auch persönlich sehr wichtig
denn auch dabei geht es wieder um
respekt ich will dass eine berufliche
ausbildung im dualen system in
deutschland genauso viel anerkennung
erhält wie das studium
darum sollen alle jugendlichen die einen
ausbildungsplatz suchen auch einen
ausbildungsplatz bekommen damit das
klappt haben wir eine
ausbildungsgarantie
vereinbart
für viele junge leute die sich aber für
ein studium entscheiden werden wir die
ausbildungsförderung verbessern vor 50
jahren wurde das bafög eingeführt es war
eine errungenschaft für mehr
chancengleichheit
wir werden das bafög eltern unabhängiger
machen die geplante kinderkrippe
die kindergrundsicherung ist eine
basisfinanzierung für studierende wir
werden zugleich die freibeträge und die
altersgrenzen annehmen damit mehr
studierende zugang zum bafög bekommen
und wir werden prüfen ob wir den
darlehensanteil senken können
gleich
zugleich endet die berufliche bildung
nicht mit der erst ausbildung erst recht
nicht angesichts der transformation die
wir schon jetzt erleben und in den
nächsten jahrzehnten noch erleben werden
die welt wird digitaler wir müssen
klimaneutral werden viele tätigkeiten
können von robotern und künstlicher
intelligenz erledigt werden aber bei
weitem nicht alle die arbeit da bin ich
sicher wird uns nicht ausgehen aber die
tätigkeiten und aufgaben werden sich
verändern berufliche weiterbildung wird
immer wichtiger
darum verbessern wir das aufstiegs bafög
für diejenigen die sich für diesen weg
entscheiden mit höheren fördersätzen und
freibeträgen sorgen wir dafür dass auch
eine zweite vollqualifizierende
ausbildung gut möglich ist auch die
augen arbeitsförderung richten wir
stärker auf weiterbildung aus mit einer
bildungs zeit und ein qualifizierungs
geld das sich am kurzarbeitergeld
orientiert klar ist ebenfalls dass wir
in deutschland deutlich mehr
arbeitskräfte brauchen darum werden wir
unser einwanderungsrecht modernisieren
und ergänzen auf der basis eines neuen
punktesystems erleichtern wir
ausländischen arbeitskräften die
jobsuche in deutschland gleichzeitig
steuern wir damit gezielt den zugang zum
deutschen arbeitsmarkt das ist ein
fortschritt
und wichtig ist deshalb auch dass wir
bildungs und berufsabschlüsse aus dem
ausland leichter und schneller
anerkennen
meine damen und herren mehr förderung
wollen wir auch in der grundsicherung
das ist gut dass wir ein sozialsystem
mit einer grundsicherung haben für alle
die nicht oder die nicht mehr über
andere systeme abgesichert sind aber
besser ist es wenn eine grundsicherung
nicht oder zumindest nicht lange in
anspruch genommen werden muss
was im volksmund hartz 4 heißt ersetzen
wir durch ein neues bürgergeld
es hat sich in der pandemie bewährt in
den ersten beiden jahren das vermögen
stärker zu schonen und die
angemessenheit der wohnung nicht zu
überprüfen das ist fair und entlastet
die betroffenen die
eingliederungsvereinbarung
ersetzen wir durch eine teilhabe
vereinbarung wir verzichten nicht auf
mitwirkungspflichten aber wir
verschaffen den vorrang ab dass man sich
nicht gleich qualifizieren kann wenn das
gut ist da zum beispiel einen
qualifizierten beruf gelernt hat und in
die grundsicherung rutscht sollte die
chance haben sich weiterzubilden oder
einen neuen beruf zu erlernen
auch das respekt vor dem beruf und der
lebensleistung
es bleibt beim prinzip fördern und
fordern aber wir fördern mehr und wir
fördern besser als bisher
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir wollen frauen und wenn dann
gleichermaßen eine gute beschäftigung
biografie ermöglichen und zugleich den
fachkräftebedarf sichern das geht wenn
wir beruf und familie noch besser
vereinbar machen
das elterngeld ist ein erfolgsmodell
und wir wollen es noch besser machen es
soll sich lohnen denn eltern die zeit
für erziehung pflege und erwerbsarbeit
partnerschaftlich teilen dazu gehört
dass der partner oder die
partner nach der geburt zwei wochen zeit
bekommt für die familie da zu sein ohne
den urlaub anzutasten wir sprechen von
einer vergüteten freistellung und es
geht uns darum gleichzeitig die kinder
krankentage dauerhaft anzuheben das
alles hilft familien
eine große und technisch anspruchsvolle
reformen nehmen wir uns vor mit der
einführung einer neuen
kindergrundsicherung
derzeit haben wir noch verschiedene
leistungen und steuerliche regelungen
die nebeneinander existieren das ist zu
kompliziert nicht gut verständlich und
in vielen fällen auch nicht
bedarfsgerecht die kindergrundsicherung
die wir im laufe dieser
legislaturperiode einführen werden wird
aus einem sockelbetrag für jedes kind
bestehen sowie als ein zusatzbetrag der
vom einkommen der eltern abhängt die
kindergrundsicherung wird unbürokratisch
digital zu erhalten seien ein großer
fortschritt zu einem modernen
sozialstaat
gemeinsam mit den ländern werden wir die
frühkindliche bildung in den kitas
stärken bessere startchancen in sozial
benachteiligten schulen schaffen
schulischen ganztagsangebote verbessern
und mit dem digital packt 20 die
digitalisierung unter schulen
vorantreiben
eine der sehr großen sozialen fragen
unserer zeit ist das wohl
guter bezahlbarer wohnraum ist ein
menschliches grundbedürfnis aber für
viele bürgerinnen und bürger gibt es
heute gerade in unseren städten zu wenig
bezahlbare wohnung sie müssen endlos
suchen
finanziellen an ihre grenzen gehen oder
lange pendelt wege zur arbeit in kauf
nehmen der traum vom häuschen am
stadtrand oder der eigentumswohnung im
kiez bleibt für normal verdienende
familien immer öfter unerfüllt
die lage auf dem wohnungsmarkt erfordert
dass die neue bundesregierung
entschlossen handelt und das tun wir wir
schaffen ein neues ministerium für
wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
damit wir alle kraft auf diese aufgabe
konzentrieren kann
wir wollen dass in deutschland pro jahr
400.000 neue wohnungen gebaut werden
jahrhundert hunderttausend öffentlich
geförderte wir werden ein bündnis für
bezahlbaren wohnraum einberufen zusammen
mit den ländern und kommunen der bauern
wohnungswirtschaft sowie den
mieterverbänden werden wir beraten wie
wir schneller und günstiger wohnraum in
deutschland schaffen
das missverhältnis von angebot und
nachfrage auf dem wohnungsmarkt kann
aber nicht von heute auf morgen
ausgeglichen werden darum werden wir
auch in der zwischenzeit etwas tun um
den anstieg der mieten in grenzen zu
halten wir verlängern die bestehende
mietpreis bremse bis zum jahr 2029 und
wir senken den angespannten
wohnungsmärkten die kappungsgrenze in
drei jahren darf die miete dann um nicht
mehr als elf prozent steigen wenn sie
noch unterhalb der ortsüblichen
vergleichsmiete liegt mehr fairness
zwischen vermietern und mietern setzen
wir auch durch beim klimaschutz auch für
das heizen mit fossilen energien gibt es
ja bereits den co2 preis dieser dient
aber dazu dass auf klimafreundliches
heizen umgerüstet wird
mittelfristig wollen wir eine teil war
mitte einführen die grundversorgung wird
teil der miete alles darüber hinaus zeit
der mieter so besteht für beide seiten
der anreiz zum umrüsten und energie
sparen und jetzt in der übergangszeit
wollen wir im kommenden jahr eine
differenzierte kostenteilung durchsetzen
das ist gerecht
meine damen und herren die
transformation die jetzt vor uns liegt
wird auf dauer nur erfolgreich sein wenn
sie von einer breiten mehrheit der
bürger machen bürger in unserem land
getragen wird
darum werden wir die kohle regionen in
ostdeutschland und nordrhein westfalen
weiterhin solidarisch unterstützen unser
versprechen gilt niemand wird ins
bergfreie fallen die folgen des
strukturwandels bewältigen wir gemeinsam
das gilt auch im hinblick auf die großen
veränderungen in der industrie insgesamt
wir werden eine vorausschauende
strukturpolitik betreiben gezielt neue
wertschöpfung schaffen zb beim
wasserstoff oder der batteriezellen
fertigung und wir werden den
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern zur
seite stehen gerade in zeiten steigender
energiepreise werden wir darauf achten
dass energie kein luxusgut wird nicht
für unternehmen in unserem land und
nicht für die bürgerinnen und bürger
richtig ist langfristig wird fossile
energie auf berechenbare weise teurer
dass sarah bei menschen mit kleinem
geldbeutel nicht überfordern eine warme
wohnung ist ein grundrecht die fahrt mit
dem auto zur arbeit oder zum supermarkt
ist für viele schlichtweg notwendig
gute klima politik fordert nicht
verzicht sondern sie ermöglicht den
umstieg auf klimafreundliche
alternativen
und vor allem deshalb werden wir private
haushalte unternehmen schon im jahr 2023
von der eeg-umlage befreien und diese
zukünftig aus dem bundeshaushalt
refinanzieren
das entlastet eine vierköpfige familie
pro jahr im vergleich zu 221 um rund 300
euro und s reduziert den bürokratischen
aufwand für unternehmen und staat der
den vergangenen 20 jahren rund um die
eeg umlage entstanden ist so entsteht
auch ein neuer rückenwind für den
umstieg auf e autos und wärmepumpen der
co2 preis fahrt bleibt stabil deshalb
haben wir uns darauf verständigt dass
wir benzin öl und gas nicht zusätzlich
verteuern wir werden außerdem das
wohngeld modernisieren eine
klimakomponente einführen und an
einmaligen heizkostenzuschuss für
wohngeldempfänger zahlen
auch an anderer stelle sorgen wir dafür
dass die bürgerinnen bürger mehr geld
zur verfügung haben
so werden wir die bedingungen für midi
jobs verbessern indem wir die
verdienstgrenze auf bis zu 1600 euro
erhöhen dadurch profitieren mehr
beschäftigte von den reduzierten
sozialbeiträgen
und wir erhöhen die anreize für
derzeitige midijob ihrer arbeitszeit in
richtung einer vollzeitstelle weiter zu
erhöhen mit erhöhung des mindestlohns
sehen wir auch die grenze für mini-jobs
auf 520 euro an
das urteil des bundesfinanzhofs zur
rentenbesteuerung werden wir rasch
umsetzen nicht erst 225 sonne schöpft
schon ab dem übernächsten jahr werden
die beiträge zur rentenversicherung als
sonderausgabe voll abzugsfähig sein das
ist eine steuerentlastung für millionen
bürgerinnen und bürger
zudem werden wir den steuerpflichtigen
teil der ausgezahlten renten langsamer
ansteigen lassen als bisher im gesetz
vorgesehen das ist eine steuerentlastung
für viele künftige rentnerinnen und
rentner
meine damen und herren
heute ist deutschland ein land von
ungeheurer innere vielfalt die
bundesregierung begreift diese
gesellschaftliche vielfalt als eine der
großen stärken unseres landes
sie verwechselt zusammenhalt nicht mit
homogenität sondern sie schafft die
rahmenbedingungen dafür dass
zusammenhalt aus der vielfalt heraus
möglich ist sie schützt die sicherheit
der bürgerinnen bürger und schafft die
voraussetzung für eine gesellschaft des
respekts zum demokratischen gemeinwesen
gehört ein handlungsfähiger rechtsstaat
der freiheit und sicherheit garantiert
wer bei der polizei oder beim zoll bei
sicherheitsbehörden oder ordnungsämtern
arbeitet verdient unseren respekt meine
damen und herren
die arbeit ist oft hart und die aufgaben
werden immer umfangreicher gerade jetzt
etwa bei der durchsetzung der
notwendigen auflagen zur bekämpfung der
korona pandemie im namen der gesamten
bundesregierung danke ich allen die tag
und nacht auf der straße und in
schwierigen situationen die sicherheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger und die
ordnung unseres gemeinwesens
gewährleisten
aber auch diese anerkennung muss hand
und fuß haben darum werden wir für die
gute personal und sachausstattung der
bundespolizei sorgen und diese als
dienstherr attraktiver machen
die schwerpunkte der arbeit der
sicherheitsbehörden in den nächsten
jahren werden auf dem kampf gegen
extremismus und organisiert ihre
organisierte kriminalität gelegt werden
dazu gehören prävention die
radikalisierung und gefahrenabwehr und
ausdrücklich teile ich die einschätzung
der bundesinnenminister die größte
bedrohung für unsere demokratie ist der
rechtsextremismus darum werden wir diese
gefahren allerersten hat gefällt
sie wurden konzepte für demokratie
förderung für die stärkung der
zivilgesellschaftlichen beratung und für
präventionsangebote werden wir jetzt
nutzen und ein demokratie fördergesetz
auf den weg bringen
wir werden entschieden gegen
organisierte kriminalität in jeder form
vorging das effektivste mittel dafür
besteht darin diesen strukturen den
geldhahn abzudrehen
darum werden wir die
geldwäschebekämpfung stärken immobilien
würden künftig nicht mehr mit bargeld
bezahlt werden können
der pakt für den rechts den pakt für den
rechtsstaat werden wir verstetigen und
um einen digital pack für die justiz
weiter wer braucht schnelle und
effiziente gerichtsverfahren
gerichtsverhandlung sollen deshalb auch
online geführt werden können und wir
werden sicher stehen schön dass täter
vom hass und hetze im netz identifiziert
und strafrechtlich belangt werden
meine damen und herren deutschland ist
ein einwanderungsland
darum ist es höchste zeit dass wir uns
auch als einwanderungs und
integrationsgesetz schafft begreifen
dazu gehört dass wir
den weg zur deutschen
staatsangehörigkeit erleichtern so so
ermöglichen wir
nur wo ermöglichen wir volle politische
teilhabe und damit bessere integration
ein bürger künftig in der regel bereits
nach fünf jahren aufenthalt in
deutschland möglich sein
und wir werden die mehrfach
staatsangehörigkeit ermöglichen es
entspricht der lebenswirklichkeit vieler
eingewandert in unserem land dass sie
ihre herkunft identität in rechtlicher
hinsicht auch nach der einbürgerung
erhalten
mit dem bekenntnis zur
einwanderungsgesellschaft geht einher
dass wir viel stärker als bisher
repräsentanz möglich machen werden das
gilt gerade in der öffentlichen
verwaltung darum werden wir ein
partizipations gesetz vorlegen um diesen
anforderungen besser gerecht zu werden
wir werden eine vernunft geleitete
migrationspolitik betreiben die legale
migration befördert und irreguläre
migration reduziert dazu gehören zügige
asylverfahren sowie gute perspektiven
für diejenigen die in deutschland gut
integriert sind dazu gehören aber auch
die konsequente rückführung besonders im
fall von straftätern und gefährdet
meine damen und herren nicht selten bei
unserer gesellschaft in den vergangenen
jahren moderner als staat und regierung
längst überfällig ist daher die
nachholende modernisierung die diese
bundesregierung auf den gebieten der
gleichstellung der körperlichen
selbstbestimmung zu dem familienrecht
auf den weg bringen wird
wir werden dafür sorgen dass unser
familienrecht unser personenstand zum
strafrecht in der gelebten wirklichkeit
ankommt
wir werden das institut der
verantwortungsgemeinschaft einführen und
das adoptionsrecht reformieren
das transsexuellengesetz werden wir
durch einen selbstbestimmung der gesetz
ersetzen
wir wollen dass ärzte märz der
öffentliche informationen über
schwangerschafts abbrüche bereitstellen
können ohne eine straftat vorliegt
hier werden wir den paragrafen 219 a aus
dem strafgesetzbuch streichen
und wir sind uns einig wir werden den
gleichbehandlungs artikel 3 des
grundgesetzes um ein verbot der
diskriminierung wegen sexueller
identität ergänzen
und wir werden diese trasse im
grundgesetz ersetzen
meine damen und herren im kulturellen
leben liegen die fundamente auf denen
unser zusammenleben gegründet ist in
ihrer ganzen vielfalt fördern kulturelle
und künstlerische impulse den aufbruch
denn unsere gesellschaft jetzt braucht
der kampf gegen die pandemie hat es
nötig gemacht entscheidungen zu treffen
die genau dieses kulturelle leben
besonders hart getroffen haben um so
mehr wird sich die neue bundesregierung
darum kümmern die soziale lage der
künstlerinnen und kreativen zu
verbessern und das kulturelle leben in
unserem land zu einer neuen blüte zu
führen
meine damen und herren die
bundesregierung bekennt sich zur
europäischen einigung sie würden aber
auch hier nicht bei bekenntnissen stehen
bleiben das gelingen europas ist unser
wichtigstes nationales anliegen
europas einigung wurde betrieben mit dem
ziel des ausgleichs zwischen früheren
fein sie gründet auf den erfahrungen der
düstersten kapitel unserer gemeinsamen
geschichte in denen unser land so viel
leid über europa und die welt gebracht
hat
diese zentrale mission der europäischen
union die wahrung des inneren friedens
europas hat nichts an ihrer aktualität
verloren
nehmen wir dieses kostbare gut welches
mutige frauen und männer über jahrzehnte
aufgebaut haben niemals als gegeben es
bedarf unseres andauernden engagement
aber dabei dürfen wir nicht stehen
bleiben worum geht es heute
wollen wir in einer welt von bald zehn
milliarden menschen noch vorkommt wollen
wir gehört werden wollen wir nicht zum
spielball fremder mächte werden und
wollen wir unseren europäischen way of
life selbstbewusst verteidigen dann geht
das nur gemeinsam als europäische union
zusammenhalt und souveränität das ist
die aufgabe für europa für das gelingen
des souveränen europas trägt unser land
eine besondere verantwortung nicht nur
wegen unserer geschichte als größte
volkswirtschaft im zentrum unseres
kontinents mit einer geschichte von
teilung und wiedervereinigung können wir
nicht kommentieren am rand steht das
instrument unserer europapolitik darf
nicht die schnelle in politische
schlagzeile sein es muss in der
beharrlichen bereitschaft bestehen
brücken zu bauen durch beständiges
engagement und verhandlungen so haben es
meine vorgängerin und meine vorgänger
gehalten und das wird auch mein handeln
leiten
die europafreundliche ausrichtung aller
demokratischen parteien in diesem haus
ist keine selbstverständlichkeit
sie ist ein schatz bei allen differenzen
in der sache lassen sie uns diesen
schatz bewahren
zu recht erwarten die bürgerinnen und
bürger das europa handlungsfähiger wird
wir wollen hier für die möglichkeiten
des lissabonner vertrags nutzen es muss
zur regel werden dass wir in europa mit
qualifizierter mehrheit entscheiden
können im rat auch auf den gebieten wo
das heute nicht der fall ist das ist
kein verlust dass es ein gewinn an
souveränität
und wir müssen auch immer bereit seinen
gruppen von staaten lösung
auszuprobieren denn noch nicht alle so
weit sind so wie wir es bereits bei
schengen gemacht haben beim euro oder
auch in der sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik
wir brauchen eine europäische politische
kultur eine kultur des konstruktiven
streits im sinne eines gemeinsamen
ringsum dem besten weg
respektvoll in anerkennung unserer sehr
unterschiedlichen geschichte der
vielfalt unserer politischen geografie
aber stets im bewusstsein all dessen was
uns als europäer verbindet
europa politik ist das ist es doch allen
klar schon lange keine außenpolitik mehr
europäische politik betrifft längst den
alltag jeder einzelnen bürger und jedes
einzelnen bürgers europa politik ist zu
einem großen teil unserer innenpolitik
geworden
europa muss zusammenstehen jedes
europäische land hat seine nationalen
interessen die müssen sie nicht
verstecken aber alle und gerade wir
müssen kompromissfähig seien keine
auseinandersetzung darf dem zusammenhalt
europas oder zentrale errungenschaften
die offene grenzen zwischen den
mitgliedstaaten oder die gemeinsame
währung infrage stellen das europäische
wiederaufbauprogramm reaktionen auf die
korona krise ist beispielhaft für diese
neue einigkeit europas in stunden der
krise
wir wollen das nutzen in europa
resilient und zukunftsfähig zu machen
meine damen und herren europa ist eine
wehrhafte demokratie gegründet auf
freiheit menschenwürde demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit
allen mitgliedstaaten
alle mitgliedsstaaten haben sich auf
diese werte verpflichtet hat sie unsere
gemeinschaft beitragen die
bundesregierung bekennt sich zu diesen
werten und sie wird bei ihrer
verteidigung klar und eindeutig an der
seite der europäischen kommission als
der hüterin der verträge stehen
ich freue mich dass sich der
französische staatspräsident bei seiner
jüngsten rede im europäischen parlament
ausdrücklich auf unseren
koalitionsvertrag bezogen und
unterstützung für einige unserer
reformvorschläge bekundet hat
frankreich ist unser engster verbündeter
und die deutsch-französische
freundschaft das unverzichtbare
fundament der europäischen union die
bundesregierung
wird keinen politischen vorstoß
unternehmen ohne ängste konsultation mit
unseren französischen freunden
die deutsch französische verständigung
ist die notwendige bedingung für
fortschritte in europa aber wissen auch
sie ist noch keine hinreichende
bedingung die zukunft europas wird weder
in paris noch in berlin entschieden
gerade unser land hat eine besondere
verantwortung auch die interessen der
östlichen mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union und unsere
osteuropäischen nachbarn mitzudenken
gerade habe ich mit dem polnischen
ministerpräsident über die lage an der
grenze zu belarus gesprochen und ihm
unsere solidarität versichert
grenzen müssen unantastbar bleiben und
der zynische missbrauch von geflüchteten
für hybride attacken auf unserer
östlichen nachbarn muss aufhören das
werden wir beim europäischen rat morgen
noch einmal bekräftigen
wir blicken in diesen tagen auch mit
großer sorge auf die sicherheitslage an
der russisch-ukrainischen grenze wir
werden hier über beim europäischen rat
und beim heutigen gipfel der östlichen
partnerschaft intensiv beraten
aber lassen sie mich
sollten es noch nicht alle verstanden
haben hier wiederholen was meine
amtsvorgängerin gesagt hat jede
verletzung territorialer integrität wird
ihren preis einen hohen preis haben und
wir werden hier mit unseren europäischen
partnern und unseren transatlantischen
verbündeten mit einer stimme sprechen
gleichzeitig sind wir zum konstruktiven
dialog bereit vor dem hintergrund
unserer geschichte muss diesem
verhältnis zu russland gerade für unser
land geld
gerade wir müssen bereit sein immer
einmal öfter den versuch der
verständigung zu unternehmen den versuch
aus der eskalationsspirale auszubrechen
so wie es etwa mit dem normandie prozess
zeitweilig gelungen ist das darf aber
nicht missverstanden werden als eine
neue deutsche ostpolitik
ostpolitik kann im vereinten europa nur
eine europäische außenpolitik seien
diese gründet auf den prinzipien des
völkerrechts und der europäischen
friedensordnung auf die sich auf
russland verpflichtet hat und die es mit
der annexion der krim so schwerwiegend
verletzt hat
wir werden uns als europäische union
nicht spalten lassen das gilt auch mit
blick auf länder deren systeme nicht
demokratisch sind etwa china mit seinem
rasanten aufstieg zur technologie und
militärmacht und die chinesische führung
vertritt ihre interessen mit großem
selbstbewusstsein
deutschland und europa haben allen grund
unsere interessen ebenso selbstbewusst
und engagiert zu vertreten wir müssen
unsere china politik an dem china
ausrichten dass die real vorfinden
das heißt aber nicht dass heißt aber
auch dass wir unsere augen nicht
verschließen vor der kritischen
menschenrechtslage und verstöße gegen
universum enorm beim namen nennen das
ändert nichts daran dass sein land von
der größe und geschichte chinas an
zentralen platz im internationalen
konzert der völker hat deshalb bieten
wir china zusammenarbeit an bei
menschheits herausforderung wie der
klimakrise der pandemie oder der
rüstungskontrolle der bieten china einen
fairen wirtschaftlichen wettbewerb zu
beiderseitigen nutzen an mit gleichen
spielregeln für alle
deutschland und europa investieren in
unsere eigene politische wirtschaftliche
und technologische stärke wir nutzen die
stärke eines geeinten europas und des
binnenmarktes und für faire
wettbewerbsbedingungen für unsere
unternehmen einzutreten und auch global
den wettbewerb aufzunehmen
meine damen und herren unser wichtigster
partner hierbei sind die vereinigten
staaten mit präsident beiden eigentlich
die überzeugung dass die liberalen
demokratien der welt neu beweisen müssen
dass sie die besseren faireren
und die gerechteren antworten auf die
herausforderung des 21 jahrhunderts
liefern können
das gilt für jedes einzelne land das
gilt aber für das verhältnis der länder
untereinander den multilateralismus ist
herausgefordert und muss sich neu
beweisen
deshalb wird die bundesregierung für die
multilaterale zusammenarbeit und ihre
institutionen sich immer stark machen
die deutsch amerikanische freundschaft
und die nato sind das unverzichtbare
fundament unserer sicherheit und
soldatinnen und soldaten leisten
unentbehrlichen beitrag zum schutz
unseres landes für frieden und
internationale sicherheit sie können
sich auf die bundesregierung und auf
dieses parlament verlassen
wir werden morgen auf dem europäischen
rat erstmals über ein neues
sicherheitspolitisches grundlagen
dokument sprechen dem sogenannten
strategischen compass deutschland wird
sich an dieser diskussion aktiv
beteiligen ebenso wie an der
überarbeitung des neuen strategischen
konzepts der nato das auf den gipfel im
nächsten jahr verabschiedet werden wird
wir werden investieren um die nato
fähigkeit ziele zu erreichen in enger
abstimmung mit unserem partner für uns
ist wichtig europäische sicherheit und
transatlantische sicherheit gehen hand
in hand
deutschland unterstützt deshalb eine
neue eu nato erklärung die wir nun rasch
verabschieden wollen auch dazu wollen
wir uns beim europäischen rat beraten
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
zu beginn der zwanziger jahre unseres
jahrhunderts stehen wir vor großen
aufgaben und vor großen veränderungen
die bürgern und bürger in unserem land
wissen das und ich habe eingangs dieser
rede die große frage zitiert dich
deshalb immer wieder gestellt bekommen
geht das alles gut aus für meine familie
für meine kinder für ganz normale leute
wie mich meine
antwort die antwort der bundesregierung
ist sehr klar ja das kann gut ausgehen
und ja das wird auch gut ausgehen wird
wir nehmen die herausforderung unserer
zeit an und wir sind zuversichtlich wir
werden sie bewältigen
nicht
weil wir die probleme unterschätzen
sondern weil wir einen präzisen plan
dafür haben wie wir sie lösen können und
wie es gut werden kann das moderne
deutschland unser deutschland ist ein
starkes land wir alle gemeinsam haben
nicht den geringsten grund uns vor der
zukunft zu fürchten
ganz im gegenteil
wenn wir zusammenhalten in einer
solidarischen gesellschaft des respekts
wenn wir uns ehrgeizige ziele setzen und
dem fortschritt die richtige richtung
geben wenn wir den aufbruch jetzt
entschlossen beginnen
dann werden wir nicht nur die korona
pandemie hinter uns lassen dann werden
wir deutschland auch gemeinsam
erfolgreich sein und dann werden die
bürgerinnen und bürger am ende dieses
jahrzehnts sagen ja es geht gut aus es
geht gut aus für mich es geht gut aus
für meine familie und für unser land das
ist das ziel dieser bundesregierung
dafür arbeiten wir mit all unserer kraft
und mit dieser arbeit fangen wir jetzt
an vielen dank
münster und das würdigten
regierungserklärungen die ampel sie hat
sich viel vorgenommen
olaf scholz verspricht nicht weniger als
ein jahrzehnt der zukunftsinvestitionen
deutschland strukturell fit zu machen
für das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
eines der hauptthemen natürlich auch
corona ja man werde diese krise
überwinden verspricht scholz 30
millionen impfungen bis jahresende
bleiben sein ziel deutlich kritisierte
er die zitat winzige minderheit von in
hampton extremisten aber die demokratie
wehrhaft die gesellschaft nicht
gespalten nächster redner traditionell
von der größten oppositionspartei für
die union nun ralph brinkhaus der
fraktionsvorsitzende
für die cdu/csu-fraktion ralph brinkhaus
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
vorbereitungen auf den heutigen tag habe
ich mir mal so die oppositions reden der
letzten 70 jahre durchgelesen von
bemerkenswerten persönlichkeiten kurt
schumacher fritz erich ollenhauer da
waren leute dabei wie rainer barzel wie
helmut kohl wie angela merkel wolfgang
schäuble und viele viele andere und es
waren teilweise brillante reden es waren
begeisternde reden die dort so
aufgehalten worden sind reden mit viel
inhalt aber es waren reden in der
opposition die immer auch durchzogen
waren von zwei elementen bitterkeit und
auch enttäuschung und empörung darüber
dass man nicht selbst in der regierung
ist um meine damen und herren ich möchte
deswegen hier und heute ganz anders
anfangen es ist so wir haben eine
bundestagswahl hat oder scholz ist mit
der mehrheit der frei gewählten
abgeordneten zum deutschen bundeskanzler
gewählt worden das ist demokratie das
haben sie sich verdient und deswegen
herr bundeskanzler herzlichen
glückwunsch alles gute und gottes segen
für ihre aufgabe
wir wollen eine gute bundesregierung war
eine gute bundesregierung ist gut für
das land und das allein ist der maßstab
für regierungspolitik aber auch
oppositionspolitik was ist gut fürs land
und ich habe es ihnen auch schon
persönlich gesagt großer respekt vor den
weg den sie bis dahin zurückgelegt haben
der von höhen und tiefen geprägt war und
er habe großer respekt auch vor den
grünen die sich auf 16 jahren opposition
heraus gearbeitet haben und auch herr
lindner ihm großer respekt ich habe mir
auch ihr buch noch einmal
durchgeblättert aus der armut zeigt sie
hatten dunkle tage gehabt sie sitzen
jetzt hier und darauf können sie auch zu
recht stolz sein und das respektieren
werden
meine damen und herren respekt ist aber
keine einbahnstraße
eine demokratie brauche eine starke
opposition auf augenhöhe und ob sie das
gegriffen haben können sie in den
nächsten tagen zeigen sie können zeigen
im umgang mit den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern in den ministerien den ich
ihr parteibuch haben und sie können es
auch dadurch zeigen dass sie die 70
jahre alte sitzordnung in diesem
parlament respektieren und nicht mit
ihrer mehrheit umwerfen und ich habe
gelernt
meine damen und herren dass sie das
morgen in einem antrag ohne debatte hier
durch den deutschen bundestag peitschen
wollen wie klein ist das wie klein ist
das meine damen und herren
und sie werden auch einzelne es weckt
ihren müssen sie werden respektieren
müssen dass wir in dieser opposition
auch zu schwitzen denn das ist unsere
aufgabe
und wenn ich dann gleich mit anfangen
kann mit dem zuspitzen meine damen und
herren ich erwarte von einem
bundeskanzler in der ersten
regierungserklärung nicht das eher
kleinteilig den koalitionsvertrag
repariert sondern
ich erwarte dass er die großen medien
zeit und bitte herr scholz 1 kann man
auch von ihnen erwarten sie sprechen
viel über fortschritt und zukunft
fortschritt und zukunft braucht
begeisterung diese begeisterung habe ich
in den letzten 90 minuten licht gesehen
liebe freunde kolleginnen und kollegen
und eine hand und herren
was jetzt
aber opposition bedeutet auch dass wir
uns die freiheit nehmen da wo es möglich
ist auch ja zu sagen weil wir unsere
verantwortung in diesem land sehen und
wir wissen auch dass sich jeder entwurf
perfekt sein kann da sind vier profi
genug und deswegen haben wir letzte
woche auch ja zu einem
infektionsschutzgesetz gemacht gesagt
was wir alleine besser gemacht hätten
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen 1
gehört auch dazu zur regierung und
opposition zu regierung und opposition
gehört dazu dass sie sich ihre
mehrheiten alleine besorgen müssen dass
wir erwarten dass die position beziehen
auch zu fragen wie beispielsweise der
impfpflicht und das nicht anders
parlament delegieren weil sie sich
selber in ihrer regierung nicht einig
sind nun mal aus der ersten redner einen
gedanken aufzugreifen von kurt
schumacher das war der erste spd
fraktionsvorsitzender es ist nicht
aufgabe der oppositionspolitik der
regierung zu gefallen und ein zweiter
gedanke es ist auch nicht das recht und
die aufgabe der regierung
oppositionspolitik zu bewerten zu
bewerten was konstruktiv ist und nicht
konstruktiv ist sie können nicht
gleichzeitig regierungspartei und
richter sein und das werden wir uns hier
auch nicht bieten lassen liebe politik
aber auch eine andere sache auch mal
ganz ganz klar zu stellen es wird keine
koalition in der opposition geben aus
unterschiedlichen gründen werden wir
nicht mit den linken und der afg
zusammen arbeiten und ich will ihnen das
auch bei der afg begründen wir verstehen
uns als opposition innerhalb unserer
repräsentativen parlamentarischen
demokratie sie verstehen sich als
opposition zur parlamentarischen
demokratie und deswegen können wir nicht
zusammenarbeiten
und um den neuen kolleginnen und
kollegen der afg vielleicht einen satz
mit auf den weg zu geben der da
vielleicht noch zögernd ist es gibt kein
richtiges leben im falschen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
noch meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren zu respekt gehört
auch dazu respekt zu zeigen vor das was
die vorgängerregierung geleistet haben
sie haben die haltung gelobt von angela
merkel oder shorts wir loben auch die
ergebnisse der arbeit von angela merkel
weil die letzten 16 jahre gute jahre für
dieses land war und gute jahre für
dieses land heißt dass wir ein ansehen
in der welt haben und in europa wie wir
es noch nie gehabt haben dass es eine
hohe latte für sie
gute arbeit heißt dass wir gegenüber der
regierung von gerhard schröder die
arbeitslosigkeit halbiert haben dass die
beschäftigung gestiegen ist dass die
löhne gestiegen ist dass wir sechsmal
hintereinander geschafft haben die
schwarze null zu kriegen dass die
straftaten zurückgegangen sind dass wir
mehrere internationale klima pakete auf
den weg gebracht haben das ist so ist
dass wir die erneuerbaren energie
vervierfacht dass wir den co2 ausstoß um
25 prozent gesenkt haben trotz wachstum
des bruttoinlandsproduktes trotz
bevölkerungswachstum und trotzdem mehr
mobilität und das als industrieland und
dazu gehört auch dass wir unglaublich
viel für familien getan haben und das
war nicht nur bei leibe die erhöhung des
kindergeldes und herr scholz
wir haben ja in ihrer rede mehrfach mit
dem finger auf die vorgängerregierung
gezeigt ich habe während ihrer rede eine
sms gekriegt war der eigentlich dabei ja
sie waren dabei herr scholz in den
letzten 16 jahren haben sie zwölf jahre
mitregiert und wir werden ihnen das
nicht durchgehen lassen dass sie sich
aus der alten regierung raus schleifen
und so tun als wenn sie da nichts mehr
zu tun gehabt haben und ich kann sie nur
vor einer sache waren wenn sie mit dem
finger auf die alte regierung zeigen
dann zeigen sie immer mit dem finger auf
sich selbst weil damen und ja
ist alles gute in diesem land nein
natürlich nicht ist es viel zu tun und
das haben sie auch richtig adressiert
und einmal den satz aus diesem alten
italienischen roman der leopard zu
zitieren das muss sich ändern damit
alles bleibt wie es ist auch das gute
und deswegen müssen wir uns weiter
bewegen deswegen müssen wir was tun in
diesem land und das wollen wir auch das
wollen wir mit begeisterung meine damen
und herren ich habe dort vorne oft
gesessen und der opposition
aber herr bahr schwer sich jetzt nicken
ich habe immer sehr genau verstanden was
sie nicht wollten aber ich habe nie
verstanden was sie eigentlich wollten
und dementsprechend wollen wir eine
andere opposition machen wir wollen eine
gestaltende opposition machen wir wollen
eine opposition machen wo wir unser bild
vom land durch unsere anträge
debattenbeiträge und durch unsere
diskussionen dieser regierung aufzwingen
werden und das wird unser ansatz in den
nächsten vier jahren sei man da haben
und ja
und wir haben wir haben ein bild von
diesem land wir wissen wo wir hin wollen
wir haben die großen linien und wir
haben auch die kleinen linien und
natürlich und sie haben es auch gesagt
ist das wichtigste doch erstmal dass wir
aus dieser krise herauskommen dass wir
gemeinsam aus dieser corona krise
rauskommen und wir wissen nicht wie viel
mutanten und wellen noch vor uns stehen
aber wir wissen 1 wir wissen dass
schnelles und beherztes handeln
notwendig ist und das kann ich ihnen
jetzt leider nicht ersparen herr scholz
diese schnelle und beherzte handeln
waren nicht ihre politik in den letzten
monaten im gegenteil sie und die armin
esther präsidenten die
ministerpräsidenten der spd haben
notwendige konferenzen aufgehalten das
gehört zur wahrheit auch dazu
und ich kann nur eins machen ich kann
ihnen die hand dazu reichen dass meine
fraktion dass unsere fraktion jederzeit
bereit ist die notwendigen maßnahmen zu
ergreifen übrigens auch wenn es
unpopuläre maßnahmen sind da haben sie
uns an ihrer seite
meine damen und herren wir wollen aber
auch ein nachhaltiges
generationengerechtes land und
nachhaltigkeit und
generationengerechtigkeit
heißt dass wir natürlich dafür sorgen
müssen dass die nachfolgenden
generationen in einer intakten umwelt
leben das kriegen wir hier in
deutschland nicht allein hinterher habe
ich aber wir können unseren teil dazu
leisten und das haben wir auch gemacht
wir haben 2009 10 übrigens zusammen herr
mützenich in der großen koalition das
ehrgeizigste klimaprojekt einer
industrienationen auf den weg gebracht
wir haben viel viel geld für technologie
und innovation aus es ist so dass diese
bundesregierung es war die den kohle
ausstieg beschlossen hat und dass wir es
übrigens auch war die den ausstieg aus
der kernenergie beschlossen haben die
gesetze sind da es ist so das geld ist
da und jetzt geht es um umsätzen
umsätzen umsetzen und umsetzen und der
havag sie haben die wahl nicht damit
gewonnen das hat nicht ganz geklappt
aber sie haben die wahl damit
erfolgreich gestaltet dass sie da viel
versprochen haben wir werden sie daran
messen wir werden jedes gramm co2 zählen
wir werden jede kilowattstunde
windenergie cl wir werden jedes kilo
müll zählen wir werden jeden meter
stromleitungen zählen wir werden jeden
kilometer bahntrasse zählen und das wird
unsere politik sein und wir bieten ihn
einst an ich weiß nicht ob sie das
wissen weil sie im letzten bundestag
noch nicht dabei waren wir haben
zusammen mit der spd beschlossen dass es
in diesem bundestag nachhaltigkeit sagen
nicht nur haushalts tage und haushalts
wochen sondern nachhaltig sage dass wir
uns einmal im jahr zeigt neben darüber
zu diskutieren und rechenschaft
abzulegen wie wir unsere nachhaltigkeit
ziele erreicht haben wir sollten das
fortsetzen und ich gehe sogar noch einen
schritt weiter lassen sie uns gemeinsam
nicht nur ein finanzhaushalt aufstellen
sondern ein klima haushalt aufstellen wo
wir die wichtigen kennzahlen die wir
brauchen messen und wo wir die wichtigen
kennzahlen auch hier im deutschen
bundestag debattieren meinen damit
und zum thema nachhaltigkeit
klima nachhaltig gehört wright gehört
auch das thema nachhaltige finanzen und
jetzt ist es ja so und das muss ich
ihnen zugestehen sie von der spd sie von
den grünen sind nicht unbedingt gewählt
worden für nachhaltige finanzen sie von
der fdp aber schon das war die
erwartungshaltung fdp sorgt für
nachhaltige finanzen fdp sorgt mit dafür
dass die nachfolgenden generationen
nicht die schulden ihrer eltern
abbezahlen müssen die fdp sorgt dafür
dass diejenigen leute die hier in 30
jahren sitzen auch noch
gestaltungsspielraum haben und nicht
allein damit beschäftigt sind die
schulden abzubezahlen oder die zinsen
aufzubringen wie lange hat dieses
versprechen gehalten keine fünf tage
fünf bar ist die sonne aufgegangen
danach bricht christian lindner das
versprechen des soliden nachhaltigen
finanzen der länder was sie da mit ihrem
nachtragshaushalt morgen machen wollen
was sie damit ihren nachtragshaushalt
morgen machen wollen wo sie
corona mittel um schreiben wollen für
ihre ampel projekte da hat jemand gesagt
da macht der herr lindner ein
taschenspielertrick nein mag diesen
begriff auch nicht taschenspielertricks
in der politik es ist kein
taschenspielertrick sondern es ist ein
segen an den fundamenten der
schuldenbremse und der finanziellen
solidität und herr lindner
verhindert wissen sie
wenn sie dabei den staatsfinanzen nach
fünf tagen schon mit anfragen dann warte
ich nur dort drauf wie lange es dauert
mit steuererhöhungen kommen wir sind
gespannt meine damen und herren
und
zum thema nachhaltigkeit gehört auch
nachhaltigkeit der sozialsysteme da
hätten wir bei der rente hubert usa
liefern müssen wir haben es nicht
gemacht sie haben sie nicht gemacht wir
haben auch nicht darauf gedrängt keine
kritik aber wir müssen jetzt liefern
weil wir genau wissen dass unser
rentensystem
2025 eine reform brauche ich finde das
gut und richtig dass sie eine aktien
rente und dass die kapitalgedeckte
elemente eingefügt haben aber wir alle
wissen doch das reicht nicht wir
brauchen eine grundlegende rentenreform
sie dagegen machen versprechen sie
machen versprechen über mindestzeit in
denen die nicht gegenfinanziert sind und
dann sagen sie den menschen doch bitte
eins sagen sie den menschen doch das
wird zu höheren abgaben führen das wird
zu weniger leistungsgerechtigkeit führen
das wird dazu führen dass die leute
weniger netto vom brutto haben ich kann
ihnen aber auch 1 anbieten herr scholz
und erhalten ich glaube mal die frage
der reform des rentensystems das ist in
ihrer 4 punkt eine reform die regierung
überdauern wird auch wenn sie sich
wahrscheinlich vorgenommen waren wir
lange zu regieren aber es wird länger
länger wirken als sie hier regieren denn
das sind wir uns einig und deswegen
brauchen wir da einen nationalen konsens
diesen nationalen konsens bieten wir
ihnen an lassen sie uns bei der rente
zusammenarbeiten das thema ist so
wichtig für parteipolitik herzliche
bitte kommen sie oft und zu meine damen
und herren
es geht aber nicht nur um nachhaltigkeit
sondern wir wollen ein land der
wirtschaftlichen stärke weil wir das
hätte mal im koalitionsvertrag der einer
stelle vielleicht auch ein bisschen
ausführen können weil wir der meinung
sind dass alles das was verteilt wird
auch erwirtschaftet werden muss und
erwirtschaftet wird es durch möglichst
viele gut bezahlte arbeitsplätze und
diese gut bezahlten arbeitsplätze die
müssen wir sicher machen um meine damen
und herren zu diesen gut bezahlten
arbeitsplätzen und das sage ich hier
ganz ganz ausdrücklich auch für meine
fraktion gehören auch
industriearbeitsplätze es muss als
industrienationen unser ansatz sein dass
wir die industrielle basis die stärke
dieses landes nach vorne bringen und
stärken meine damen und herren dazu
brauchen wir ein wettbewerbsfähiges
unternehmenssteuerrecht ich sehe das
nicht dazu brauchen wir ein arbeitsrecht
was auf das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
passt ich sehe das nicht und dazu müssen
wir uns vor allen dingen mit zwei großen
herausforderungen beschäftigen er schaut
sie haben es gesagt das sind die großen
tech unternehmen die großen plattformen
die mittlerweile mehr macht haben als
einzelne staaten die mehr investieren
als staatengemeinschaften wir müssen die
deutschen mittelständler vor dieser
herausforderung schützen wir müssen
daran arbeiten dass wir in europa auch
wettbewerbsfähig bleiben und es gibt
eine zweite große herausforderung und
ich glaube es ist wichtig dass wir an
dieser stelle über diese herausforderung
reden das ist nämlich das thema china
china ist für unser mittelstand für
unsere wirtschaft für unseren wohlstand
eine größere herausforderung als alle
steuer und sozialgesetze die wir falsch
und richtig zusammen machen können und
deswegen brauchen wir eine
china-strategie und deswegen müssen wir
uns auch in der außenpolitik damit
beschäftigen und frau bär bord eine
werte geleitete außenpolitik ist wichtig
menschenrechte sind wichtig aber sie
haben auch eine funktion sie haben die
funktion unsere interessen unsere
wirtschaftlichen interessen zu vertreten
und auch daran werden wir sie messen
vorkehrungen
meine damen und herren sie haben leider
erst am ende herr scholz ihrer langen
rede über sicherheitspolitik gesprochen
äußere sicherheit ist in gefahr ist
bedroht und nennen wir es bei nahmen sie
haben es auch beim namen genannt in
europa durch russland punkt und ich
würde mir wünschen herrn müssten nicht
dass sie das auch mal so eindeutig
benennen und nicht immer wieder
schockieren in der spd zwischen ihrer
russland freundlichkeit und dem was
tatsächlich ist und ich sage das auch
für meine fraktion wir wissen an welcher
seite wir steht wir sind überzeugte
transatlantiker weil wir wissen wer
unsere freunde sind um wir nicht unsere
freunde sind meine an
sicherheit bedeutet aber auch innere
sicherheit und da reicht es nicht mehr
bundespolizei auf dem weg zu bringen da
reicht es nicht den pakt für den
rechtsstaat fortzusetzen sondern dazu
gehörten auch respekt und vertrauen in
unsere sicherheitsbehörden und dieser
respekt und dieses vertrauen sehe ich
nicht in ihrem koalitionsvertrag ich
sehe da immer wieder misstrauen und das
ist nicht gut wir brauchen unsere
unterstützung und die brauchen auch die
gesetzlichen grundlagen um ermitteln zu
können und dazu gehört auch der zugriff
auf daten daten bekämpfen terror daten
bekämpfen kindesmisshandlung und weil
ich ja weiß dass diese koalition ganz
besonders ist die spd sind datenschützer
die grünen sind noch größere
datenschützer die fdp sind die
allergrößten datenschützer meilen damen
und ja aber vielleicht ein hinweis dazu
der datenschutz muss den menschen dienen
und nicht die menschen den datenschutz
und da ist einiges durcheinandergeraten
meine damen und herren zur
sicherheit und ordnung gehört auch das
thema migration und ich sage jedes land
hat das recht migration steuern und zu
kontrollieren
jedes land hat das recht auch zu
definieren was seine
aufnahmebereitschaft und
aufnahmefähigkeit ist und was sie nicht
ist und sie sagen sie wollen das anders
machen mir persönlich macht das angst
was sie vorhaben sie wollen offene
grenzen haben sie wollen einen
schnelleren zugang zum sozialsystem
sie wollen einen besseren zugang zum
gesundheitssystem und sie wollen vor
allen dingen durch ihr spurwechsel
illegale migration schneller
legalisieren ich halte das für eine
gefährliche mischung dass wir haben wir
nicht mitmachen die bekunden die
hauptprobleme
und wenn sie das thema integration
ansprechen was sie dankenswerterweise
gemacht haben wir haben es leider nicht
geschafft die menschen die 2015 und 2016
gekommen sind hubertus heil in den
arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren wir haben
viel zu hohe summen von menschen die im
hartz-iv-system sind und ich denke mal
ist unsere gemeinsame aufgabe das zu
ändern das haben sie in der letzten
legislaturperiode nicht geschafft das
müssen wir hinkriegen und das müssen wir
schaffen und ja damit sind wir bei
unseren sozialstaat sozialstaat ist für
uns unserer dna
und dna bedeutet dass wir einen behüten
sozialstaat haben wollen dass die
menschen sich darauf verlassen können
dass wenn sie fallen ihnen geholfen wird
das wenn sie in schwierigen situationen
sind dass ihnen geholfen wird aber dass
die gesellschaft sich auch darauf
verlassen kann dass jeder der in diesem
sozialstaat drin ist alles dafür tut um
da wieder rauszukommen und deswegen geht
es nicht nur um einen fördernden
sozialstaat sondern es geht auch um
einen fordernden sozialstaat und das
bürgergeld was sie auf den weg bringen
ist das gegenteil davon das ist die
vorstufe zum bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen das meine damen und
herren mitmachen und das können wir
nicht mitmachen
vielleicht noch ein aspekt
wenn wir sagen wie wir uns das land
vorstellen wir stellen uns das land und
die politik so vor dass auch politik für
die leise mittel gemacht wird und das
nicht nur politik gemacht wird für die
lauten für die aggressiven politik
gemacht wird für diejenigen die sich
besonders gut artikulieren können die in
den talkshows die in den medien
vertreten
und diese leise mittel der gesellschaft
das sind insbesondere die familien die
familie müssen kern unserer politik sein
und zwar ganz von anfang an familien mit
kindern das thema bildung über das viel
zu wenig gesprochen worden ist in ihrer
regierungserklärung gerade in zeiten von
corona und das geht weiter mit der
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf und
hört am ende des lebens auf und ich kann
ihnen ein versprechen das wird kern
unserer sozialpolitik sein familie in
den generationen und wenn sie da gute
dinge auf den weg bringen dann werden
sie uns an ihrer seite haben herr schulz
und es geht
um eine sache die uns im wahlkampf
wichtig war weil wir auch in der letzten
legislaturperiode das ist auch
selbstkritik gesehen haben dass wieder
große defizite haben wir müssen unseren
staat
modernisieren wir haben einen guten
start eine gute verwaltung haben ein
gutes gesundheitssystem aber ehrlich
gesagt wenn wir nichts tun werden wir
das alles in den nächsten jahren
verlieren wir haben das in corona
gesehen wo die defizite sind und ich
möchte drei aspekte nennen wir sind
nicht genügend vorbereitet auf
katastrophen wir sind nicht genügend
vorbereitet auf pandemien und
wahrscheinlich wird die nächste
katastrophe keine panne sein wir haben
da kein gutes zusammenspiel zwischen
bund und ländern die haben keine
notstandsgesetzgebung dafür wir müssen
da was tun da haben sie uns an ihrer
seite wir sind nicht digital genug in
der verwaltung da beißt die maus keinen
faden ab da sind wir wirklich schlecht
was ich nur nicht verstehe herr scholz
warum machen sie das nicht zur chefsache
warum lagern sie alle kompetenz für
diesen bereich digitalisierung der
inneren verwaltung an andere ministerien
aus ist ihnen das nicht so wichtig und
sie ist es wichtig und wir werden in den
nächsten jahren dafür kämpfen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren
wir haben viele dinge zu tun wir haben
viele ideen als unionsfraktion dieser
ideen die werden wir auch einbringen
selbstbewusst und wissen wo wir
herkommen und das möchte ich auch noch
mal eins klarstellen an dieser stelle
möchte klarstellen wir haben unsere
wurzeln und unsere wurzeln liegen in
unsere werte diese werte sind christlich
und christlich bedeutet nicht dass wir
in der katholischen evangelischen kirche
sind sondern christlich bedeuten dass
wir wissen dass wir nicht die letzte
instanz sind dass wir nicht alles regeln
müssen dass wir nicht alles regeln
können und das immunisiert uns als union
gegen jegliche moralische
überheblichkeit und das wird uns auch
weiterhin nehmen es ist so dass
christlich bedeutet
das christliche leuten dass wir ein
menschenbild haben beim menschenbild was
von eigenverantwortung ausgeht ein
menschenbild was von solidarität ausgeht
ein menschenbild was auch von freiheit
rausgeht und vor allen dingen einem
menschenbild was das leben bedingungslos
schütz und zwar vom anfang des lebens
bis zum ende des lebens weiter
wir sind
demokratisch und demokratisch bedeutet
es dass wir hier für diese
parlamentarische demokratie kämpfen
gegen die feinde von rechts es gibt
leider auch verein gefunden links und
auch gegen die werden wir kämpfen meine
damen und herren es gibt eine
entwicklung
die macht mir sorgen das macht mir
sorgen dass
aktivisten
nichtregierungsorganisationen die alle
ihren zweck die alle ihre bedeutung
haben dass die zunehmend an bedeutung
gewinnen das räte dass kommission mehr
bedeutung haben als die frei gewählten
abgeordneten repräsentativ gewählten
abgeordneten den deutschen bundestag und
deswegen meine damen und herren ist es
so dass wir darum kämpfen sollten wir
sind hier das höchste frei gewählte
verfassungsorgan das sollten wir auch
sehr sehr selbstbewusst verteidigen
meine damen und herren
wir sind die union
das bedeutet wir haben ein tiefes
verständnis dafür dieses land
zusammenzuhalten übrigens die soziale
union sozial auch deswegen war gewissen
und das haben wir in kona weidlich
diskutiert dass freiheit auch immer die
freiheit der schwachen gästen nicht nur
die freiheit der starken ist und wir
sind die union und ihr haben den tiefen
anspruch dieses land zusammenzuhalten
nicht um jeden preis das wird nicht
gehen wir werden nicht alle irgendwo
mitnehmen können und wir haben auch den
tiefen anspruch europa zusammenzuhalten
weil wir wissen herr scholz dass europa
die lösung ist für ganz ganz viele
unserer probleme ob's außenpolitische
sachen sind situations politik ist ob
sein europa ist was technologie und
industriepolitik machen was einen
gemeinsamen digitalen und kapitalmarkt
macht und deswegen müssen wir auch
dieses europa zusammenhalten aber wir
werden dieses europa nicht
zusammenhalten wenn wir aus diesen
europa eine schuldenunion machen meine
damen und herren wir werden dieses
europa nicht zusammenhalt in dem wir
eine gemeinsame arbeitslosenversicherung
und der lindner ich sie werden anfang
januar ihre ausführungen machen wir
setzen da auf sie dass sie das
verhindern was olaf scholz und die
grünen eigentlich wollen und wir werden
das auch sehr genau bewerten wir sind
christlich wir sind demokratisch wir
sind sozial sind die union wir sind
getragen von tiefen will in den nächsten
jahren dieses land zusammenzuhalten und
deswegen herr bundeskanzler bieten wir
ihnen auch die zusammenarbeit an daraus
auch um die fragen der nationalen und
europäischen interessiert aber sie
werden auch verständnis dafür haben dass
ist uns nicht so ganz gefällt dass sie
da sitzen wir würden lieber jemanden von
uns sitzen haben das ist doch überhaupt
keine frage weil wir auch glauben wir
könnten es besser sie sehen das
natürlich anders aber das ist demokratie
und das kann auch spaß machen und
deswegen bieten wir ihnen ein sun sie
bieten ihnen an dass wir die debatte
führen dass wir den streit führen dass
wir uns dringend darum bemühen gute und
bessere lösungen für dieses land zu
finden und wir haben glaube ich eine
große chance meine damen und herren wenn
wir das richtig machen und wenn wir das
gut machen wenn wir bei diesem streit
ferne fähre standards setzen dann ist es
so dann können wir auch ein vorbild sein
für eine gesellschaft die insbesondere
in den sozialen medien aber nicht nur
dort immer rascher und immer rauer und
ich glaube das sollte unser anspruch
sein hier als deutscher bundestag dass
wir da ein vorbild sind und dass wir die
diskussion so führen dass die menschen
sich an diesen diskussionen orientieren
können und
meine damen und herren es
ist so dass wir sicherlich jetzt alle
das ganz große ziel haben corona zu
überwinden aber es geht nicht nur um die
überwindung der infektion ich weiß nicht
wer sich von ihnen noch an den sommer
2006 erinnert als wir die
fußball-weltmeisterschaft gehabt haben
und als das die welt erstaunt war dass
deutschland an land ist was lächeln kann
wir haben dieses lächeln in den letzten
jahren insbesondere in den letzten zwei
jahren verloren es muss unser
gemeinsames ziel sein dass wir dieses
lächeln wieder zurückgewinnen und so war
wir politik machen so wollen wir
engagiert politik machen herzlichen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
das war der fraktionsvorsitzende der
union der übrigens immer frei ohne
manuskript spricht brinkhaus sollte der
neuen regierung anfangs respekt um sie
dann aber heftig zu kritisieren
es fehlten die großen linien klare
position zur impfpflicht zum beispiel so
brinkhaus heftige kritik auch an
finanzminister lindner der seine
wahlversprechen einer soliden
finanzierung nicht heute klar grenzte er
sich ab von der afg eine koalition in
der opposition werde es nicht geben
nächste gegnerin ist nun katharina dröge
die neue fraktionsvorsitzende von
bündnis 90 grüne die technischen
probleme eben bitte ich zu entschuldigen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrter
herr brinkhaus ich habe ihn wirklich
sehr aufmerksam zugehört und ich danke
ihnen für das angebot konstruktiv mit
uns als neuer regierung
zusammenzuarbeiten
die grüne waren selber viele jahre in
der opposition und wissen es zu schätzen
ein gutes verhältnis zwischen regierung
und opposition ist gerade in zeiten von
krisen es gerade angesichts der
herausforderungen vor denen wir aktuell
stehen notwendig
aber
ich habe ihn auch sehr genau zugehört
bei dem was sie gesagt haben und da kann
ich nur sagen es wurde dringend zeit es
wurde dringend zeit auf dieses land
endlich eine neue regierung bekommt eine
regierung die handelt eine regierung die
die herausforderungen der zukunft ewig
angeht hier etwas möglich macht die
nicht nur darüber spricht was nicht geht
er bringt aber sie haben ja einen sehr
energischen vortrag gehalten aber so
energisch haben sie nicht regiert in den
letzten jahren ihre regierungspolitik
eines wissen ihrer regierung es darf
immer nur daraus class dann zu tun wenn
es wirklich gar nicht mehr anders
möglich war und das größte thema wo das
exemplarisch ist dass sie eben nicht
gehandelt haben das ist der kampf gegen
die klimakrise nirgends wurde in den
letzten jahren so wenig das notwendige
getan wie hier und es ist derzeit nicht
erbringen haus das konkreteste warf sie
zum thema ökologische nachhaltigkeit in
ihrer rede gesagt haben das thema
nachhaltigkeit wochen im deutschen
bundestag sind das ist keine konkrete
maßnahme wir
wir legen einen koalitionsvertrag vor
mit dem wir endlich ins handeln kommen
diese koalition hat sich darauf
verpflichtet auf den 1,5 grad zu kommen
und ehrlich gesagt bringt eigentlich
sollte das eine selbstverständlichkeit
sein das schulden wir unseren kindern
das schulden wir kommenden generation
dass alle die ihr in diesem bundestag
dafür gewählt sind verantwortung zu
tragen auch dafür sorgen dass unsere
kinder im jahr 2050 wenn der bagger
klimavertrag sein ziel definiert hat
dass sie da in einer welt leben die noch
lebenswert ist das sollte
selbstverständlich sein
und natürlich ist das was vor uns liegt
eine große herausforderung das tempo des
wandels dass wir jetzt brauchen um diese
ziele noch zu erreichen sind eine große
herausforderung aber auf der anderen
seite liegt darin auch eine große chance
wir können miteinander wenn wir handeln
die 20 20er jahre die so entscheidend
sind im kampf gegen die klimakrise zum
jahrzehntes klimaschutzes machen im
bereich der energieerzeugung bringen wir
endlich das tempo in den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien jahrelang haben
wir energieminister in diesem land
erlebt die sich absurderweise irgendwie
als ausbau bremse der erneuerbaren
energien verstanden haben und nicht als
motor das ändern wir jetzt
wir hatten sogar die absurde situation
hier im deutschen bundestag dass selbst
die wirtschaft darum betteln musste dass
der ausbau der erneuerbaren voran kommt
dass die briefe schreiben musste am
peter altmeier und damit endlich etwas
passiert mit diesem koalitionsvertrag
licon wir denn da ein wir haben gesagt
80 prozent erneuerbare energien am
stromverbrauch bis zum jahre 2030 das
ist das konkrete ziel und wir unterlegen
dass auch mit maßnahmen mit einer
solarpflicht auf allen geeigneten
dächern mit restlichen flächen zielen
für die windkraft und mit einer
deutlichen beschleunigung von
planungsprozessen
gleichzeitig ziehen wir den
kohleausstieg vor und retten damit die
dörfer im rheinischen revier es ist eine
frage des schutzes von heimat dass
menschen nicht mehr aus den dörfern
ausziehen müssen die sinnlos abgebaggert
werden zugunsten einer kohlepolitik die
gegen die zukunft unserer kinder steht
aber wir denken die klimaneutralität in
allen sektoren das heißt auch in der
verkehrspolitik diese koalition hat klar
gesagt wir steigen aus dem
verbrennungsmotor aus wir schaffen 15
millionen neue elektro mit elektroautos
bis 2030 wir bauen die infrastruktur für
die elektromobilität
und wir stecken mehr geld in den ausbau
der schiene und in den übrigen v und wir
werden den bundesverkehrswegeplan
überprüfen
und ich freue mich auch darauf dass wir
in dieser koalition jetzt ein
verkehrsminister haben der sagt er ist
der anwalt der fußgänger und radfahrer
wissen dann nehmen wir sie dann wort wir
wünschen uns eine gute zusammenarbeit
und der bereich der wirtschaftspolitik
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen da
berühmten wir eine neue zeit indem wir
ausgerechnet das wirtschaftsministerium
zum klimaschutz ministerium macht machen
machen wir schluss mit alten gegensätzen
wir grünen haben schon vor vielen jahren
plakatiert zwischen wirtschaft und
umwelt da gehört kein oder und es ist
gut dass diese erkenntnis jetzt endlich
auch in der deutschen bundesregierung
angekommen ist
und ich sage ihnen werte kolleginnen und
kollegen große teile der wirtschaft die
muss man davon gar nicht mehr überzeugen
denn die wissen das nur in der
klimaneutralität ihre wirtschaftliche
zukunft liegt die alten großen
industrien in diesem land stahl chemie
aluminium kupfer und zement die warte
nur darauf dass diese regierung endlich
den startschuss gibt zum umbau richte
und klimaneutrale produktion oder auch
die automobilindustrie die luftfahrt der
schiffbau die alle wissen dass sie nur
mit einer klimaneutralen mobilität mit
einer klimaneutralen produktion in
zukunft noch wettbewerbsfähig sein
können
uns alle eint übrigens auch der wunsch
dass deutschland eine infrastruktur hat
die funktioniert unter druck auf sie
haben eben gesagt die grünen stimmten
nicht für nachhaltigkeit finanziell ich
halte es für absolut nicht
generationengerecht und für absolut
nicht nachhaltig unsere infrastruktur so
warten zu lassen dass die rechnung von
künftigen generationen bezahlt werden
muss das ist finanziell nicht nachhaltig
im gegenteil ich möchte nicht in einem
land leben in dem ich mich dafür schämen
muss dass die autobahnbrücken für den
lkw verkehr gesperrt werden weil sie
einsturzgefährdet sind weil niemand in
sie investiert hat in den vergangenen
jahren ich will nicht in einem land
leben in dem ich nicht dafür schämen
muss dass es regionen gibt in denen das
internet für die menschen gerade mal so
schnell ist dass sie eine e-mail
hochladen können und in dem sie den
einzigen funkloch wurden und ich liebe
auch nicht in einem land wenn nämlich
nicht ständig darüber ärgern musste auf
die bahn zu spät kommt oder gar nicht
kommt weil es keinen anschluss gibt weil
nicht in das notwendige schienennetz
investiert haben
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir in
dieser woche einen nachtragshaushalt
vorlegen der finanzielle spielräume
ermöglicht die unterlassenen
investitionen aus der korona krise die
können wir jetzt tätigen und die könnte
gleichzeitig einsetzen zur bekämpfung
der klimakrise und
auf der anderen seite müssen wir auch
die veränderungen die vor uns liegen sie
versorgen die verursachen auch
verunsicherung und wir als koalition
gegeben darauf auch eine antwort mich
hat im sommer eine junge frau die stark
in einem großen chemiekonzern ihre
ausbildung gemacht hat wird das was ich
hier lerne eigentlich in zukunft noch
gebraucht und darauf geben wir eine
klare antwort als diese koalition das
was sie gelernt hat aber das was alle
menschen in diesem land ans fähigkeiten
mitbringen das wird in zukunft nicht nur
weiterhin gebraucht das brauchen wir
sogar dringender denn je denn ihre
fähigkeiten eurer fähigkeiten innovation
die ideen der menschen in diesem land
die sind das was dieses land stark macht
und deswegen haben wir in diesem
koalitionsvertrag erklärt dass diese
pflanzen weiter bildungsrepublik
umgebaut werden muss doch in allen
lebenslagen sei es im ausbildung im
beruf oder auch in der arbeitslosigkeit
die weiterbildung so fördern dass jeder
und jede in zukunft die bestmöglichen
chancen hat auch in einer neuen
arbeitswelt
und sicherheit bedeutet übrigens auch
dass ein land ein sozialstaat hat der
die menschen auffängt wenn es einmal
nicht so gut geht der sieger
arbeitslosigkeit unterstützt der respekt
und förderung und unterstützung in den
mittelpunkt stellt und nicht sanktionen
auch da leitet dieser koalitionsvertrag
eine wende ein
unsere kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind
sie jetzt kurz vor weihnachten und meine
kinder sie haben dem wunschzettel an den
weihnachtsmann schon geschrieben und sie
freuen sich auf weihnachten und ich
freue mich auch mit ihnen auf
weihnachten ich finde heiligen abend
etwas wunderschönes aber für viele
familien in diesem land wird das anders
sein es wird zu viele eltern in diesem
land geben die mit großen bauchschmerzen
auf heiligabend schauen weil sie wissen
dass das geld reicht nicht für die
geschenke reicht und die ihren kindern
nach erklären müssen wenn die zurück in
die kita gehen darum der weihnachtsmarkt
ihnen so viel weniger an wünschen
erfüllt hat als anderen kindern das
bricht mir das herz und ich finde es
richtig und wichtig dass dieser
koalitionsvertrag darauf jetzt endlich
eine antwort gibt das wir klar sagen
kinder haben im hartz-iv-system nichts
verloren sie gehören da nicht rein team
hatten keine kleine arbeit die kinder
sind kinder sie haben recht aber auch
erzielten gehören sie haben ein recht
auf ein gutes auftrags und aus dieser
staaten auch an uns dafür garantiert
dass sie draußen und genau deshalb ist
es so einen riesenerfolg dass in diesem
koalitionsvertrag endlich eine
kindergrundsicherung verankert wurde
diesen kindern das auch ermöglicht
dringend zeit ist es übrigens auch dass
wir in einem land leben in dem eine
politik gemacht wird wo die menschen in
all ihrer vielfalt akzeptiert werden mit
all ihren lebensentwürfen willkommen
geheißen werden anerkannt werden
unterstützt werden und respektiert
werden das hat dieser koalitionsvertrag
noch einmal deutlich gemacht mit
wichtige reform wie der abschaffung des
transsexuellen gesetzes mit mehr rechten
für alle familienformen mit einem echten
schutz vor diskriminierung und mit einer
reform des staatsangehörigkeitsrechts
und ich muss das auch in richtung
insbesondere der csu sagen es ist gut
dass dieses land nicht mehr von einer
partei regiert wird die immer wieder im
familienpolitischen
gesellschaftspolitischen debatten
unterschiedliche familien und
gesellschafts und lebensentwürfe
gegeneinander ausspielt so schwer dass
es vor kurzem noch mal zum thema der
verantwortungsgemeinschaft gemacht hat
ich kann es nicht verstehen was ist so
schlimm daran menschen mehr rechte und
mehr sicherheit zu geben niemand
wirklich niemandem wird etwas
weggenommen wenn jemand andere mehr
rechte bekommt
unsere pflichten verbunden werden so
dass mehr ordentlich geht
diese in neue regierung hat ihre arbeit
aufgenommen in einer extrem schwierigen
zeit wir befinden uns mitten in der
vierten welle der korona partien es war
richtig und wichtig dass sie miteinander
die arbeit schon aufgenommen haben bevor
diese regierung sich überhaupt
konstituiert hat denn wir mussten die
menschen schützen dafür sind wir gewählt
und ich finde es auch richtig und
wichtig dass wir endlich die debatten
über corona wieder an den ort zurück
gebracht haben wo sie hingehören nämlich
in den deutschen bundestag wir sind
diejenigen die schwierige entscheidung
treffen müssen wir irgendwie miteinander
abhängen müssen und wir haben gezeigt
dass wir das schnell und
verantwortungsvoll machen können jetzt
steht nicht an so viele menschen wie
möglich dabei zu unterstützen das sich
impfen insbesondere auch die kinder den
eltern dabei zu beraten dass auch die
kinder sich impfen werden und wir müssen
aber auch uns alle miteinander einmal
die zeit nehmen zurückzuschauen im
vergangenen sommer wenn wir alle haben
es gemeinsam nicht geschafft millionen
von menschen davon zu überzeugen sich
impfen zu lassen das müssen wir uns alle
miteinander fragen warum das nicht
funktioniert hat denn impfen ist der
einfachste der sicherste der
unkomplizierteste der beste weg raus aus
dieser krise und wir haben das nicht
geschafft und meine antwort darauf ist
prävention ist unheimlich schwierig
menschen auch von präventions-
überzeugen zu handeln dann wenn sie noch
gar nicht so genau erkennen das ist
wirklich notwendig für sie ist da müssen
wir alle besser werden prävention hat in
der vergangenheit zu wenig spielraum in
den debatten im deutschen bundestag
genommen
und sie haben ja die das angebot zur
konstruktiven zusammenarbeit gemacht und
bei diesem thema prävention der möchte
ich sie wirklich einladen wir begehen
wir stehen am beginn eines jahrzehnts
das entscheidend sein blick auf
prävention wir sind die generation die
es in der hand hat die klimakrise zu
bekämpfen die aufgabe die vor uns liegt
die ist so groß das werden wir nur alle
gemeinsam schaffen dafür braucht man die
demokratische opposition genauso wie die
regierungsfraktionen
meine kinder werden jahr 2050 ungefähr
so alt sein wie ich das heute sind sie
werden mich einmal fragen was habt ihr
damals eigentlich gemacht und ich möchte
dass wir alle die wir hier verantwortung
übernehmen unseren kindern all den
kindern in diesem land in zukunft sagen
können wir haben das geschafft und wir
haben das gemeinsam gemacht
vielen dank frau kollegin regeln
das war die neue fraktionsvorsitzende
der grünen katharina dröge für sie ist
es nicht verwunderlich höchste zeit für
eine neue regierung da die probleme
endlich angehen die vorgängerregierung
habe viel zu wenig getan vor allem für
den klimaschutz für die infrastruktur
für die familien und kinder es folgte
nun alles weide die fraktionsvorsitzende
der afd
nächste rednerin ist die kunden gehen dr
alice waibel fw fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler werte
damen und herren der lärmende fehlstart
den ihre aus linksgrünen betonköpfen und
umgefallen den liberalen zusammen
gezimmerte regierung hingelegt hat sucht
seinesgleichen
von der ersten minute an geben sie und
ihre minister auf konfrontationskurs mit
der realität mit der freiheit mit den
bürgerrechten mit den bürgern und mit
den europäischen nachbarn und partner
herr habeck und sein staatssekretär
haben sich als erstes projekt die
aushebelung des artenschutzes
vorgenommen um das land noch dichter mit
windrädern voll stellen zu können der
natur und artenschutz hat als
sympathiewerbung bei den grünen offenbar
an bedeutung verloren und das unsägliche
zensurgesetz netz tg wollte die fdp im
wahlkampf noch abschaffen jetzt stellt
sie den justizminister der die anwendung
des netz tg sogar noch verschärfen will
innenministerin feser erklärt kaum im
amt den rechtsextremismus zur größten
gefahr der allgegenwärtige ich wusste
dass sie da klatschen der
allgegenwärtige links und islam
extremismus kommt bei ihr genauso wenig
vor wie im ganzen rot grün gelben
koalitionsvertrag nicht mit einem wort
zu dem soeben mit knapper not in hamburg
verhinderten islamistischen
terroranschlag haben wir von der
innenministerin bis heute noch kein wort
gehört und dieselbe innenministerin kam
aus brüssel zurück mit der zusage von
40.000 afghan die aus unerfindlichen
gründen in die eu umgesiedelt werden
sollen gleich
25.000 allein nach deutschland zu holen
spanien und frankreich übernehmen gerade
mal ein zehntel dieser zahl und das
obwohl die asylanträge
ohnehin wieder stark ansteigen und
deutschland eu-weit mit abstand die
meisten asylbewerber aufnimmt und damit
ist klar deutschland bleibt nicht nur
auf seinem sonderweg als migrations
magnet der vorgängerregierung ihre
regierung gibt in dieser sackgasse sogar
noch vollgas und die gleiche moralische
anmaßung steckt hinter den belehrungen
die frau bär burg als außenministerin
gegenüber polen meinte verteilen zu
müssen weil das land polen seine
europäische verantwortung ernst nimmt
und die eu-außengrenze wirksam gegen
illegale migration schützt und herr
lindner
von der umfallerpartei fdp der entferner
vergangenheit gern und viel von soliden
staatsfinanzen
sprach und versprach liegt als erstes
einen nachtragshaushalt von 60
milliarden schulden vor
als notar der kommenden grün-roten
aufgaben orgien
zweckentfremdet der bundesfinanzminister
also überdimensionierte
kreditermächtigung seines vorgängers und
des bundeskanzlers um künftig noch mehr
geld für grüne klimaschutz und
energiewende planwirtschaft verpulvern
zu können was für ein start ins amt mit
unseriösen und verfassungsrechtlich
bedenklichen finanztricks herein vor
vier jahren herr lindner hieß es bei
ihnen noch lieber gar nicht regieren als
schlecht regieren heute lautete die
devise hauptsache in der regierung
sitzen als steigbügelhalter für grün
linke projekte und allmachtsfantasien
von dem einstigen geist der fdp das muss
man immer ganz klar sagen ist nichts
aber auch gar nichts mehr übrig
geblieben und inmitten dieses des
konzerts steht als kapellmeister ein
bundeskanzler der vor allem ein gerne
tut schweigen vor allem zu sein eigene
verfehlungen von comics über wirecard
bis zum millionenschweren steuer und
spendenaffäre der warburg-bank und ihre
orakel haften zweideutigkeiten nach
merkel art machen die sache nicht besser
sie sagen sie seien auch der kanzler der
ungeimpften und sortieren genau damit
die bürger in brave geimpften und
ungeimpften abweichler die sie zum
wohlverhalten zwingen wollen genau das
ist die wortwahl eines kanzlers der
spaltung
den eklatantesten wählerbetrug haben sie
sich noch vor amtsantritt geleistet den
einstieg in die vor wenigen wochen noch
hoch und heilig dementierte impfpflicht
die novelle des infektionsschutzgesetzes
wurde gegen alle guten parlamentarischen
sitten durchgepeitscht dies mit weiteren
schweren grundrechtseingriff auf
unabsehbare zeit
warum sie erst damit zu eilig hatten ist
leicht zu durchschauen das virus schert
sich nämlich nicht um ihre maßnahmen ihr
ständiges immer mehr was bisher schon
nicht funktioniert hat sie wollen
nämlich an der verfassung vorbei einen
unerklärten permanenten ausnahmezustand
etablieren und sie befürchten nämlich
dass die von ihnen geführte panik zu
schnell abebbt wenn das
infektionsgeschehen auch ohne ihr zutun
schon wieder zurückgeht sie brauchen
dauer panik und ausnahmezustand damit
weniger über das gesprochen wird was
ihre regierung sonst noch auf der agenda
hat eine migrationspolitik die noch mehr
als die vorgängerregierung die tore für
einwanderung in die sozialsysteme
eröffnet die mit erleichterten zugang zu
sozialleistungen und
aufenthaltserlaubnissen lockt die über
die großzügige ausweitung von
einbürgerungen und
familienzusammenführungen unumkehrbare
tatsachen schafft eine
klimaschutzpolitik die allen
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
bereichen übergeordnet ist und über
staatliche lenkung und staatliches geld
verteilen faktisch in sozialismus und
klima planwirtschaft mündet und in die
verarmung breiter bevölkerungsschichten
energie und sicherheit und absehbare
blackouts in europa politik die von
eigenen nationalen interessen nichts
wissen bilden die schulden und
transferunion zum nachteil der deutschen
steuerzahler weiter ausbaut und die eu
in einem europäischen bundesstaat
umbauen möchte mit diesem wunsch nach
auflösung des eigenen nationalstaates in
einem zentralstaat stehen sie europa in
europa übrigens völlig alleine da und
das alles steht bei ihnen unter dem
schlagwort
information aber eine solche macht
anmaßung ist nicht die aufgabe einer
demokratischen regierung die den bürgern
dient auf die realen sorgen und nöte
welche die ganz normalen bürger dieses
landes umtreiben haben sie keine antwort
der inflation läuft aus dem ruder und
des mittelstand und mittelschicht
verarmen die ezb ist hilflos sie müsste
mit höheren zinsen gegensteuern aber sie
sitzt gefangen in der falle der staats
und unternehmensfinanzierung von 0 und
negativzinsen die notenbanken im übrigen
eigentlich verboten ist statt die bürger
zu entlasten treibt ihre regierung
steuern sowie sprit und energiepreise
noch in die höhe und das ist
unverantwortlich sagte damen und herren
die angst um den arbeitsplatz geht um
sie aber blasen im namen des
klimaschutzes zum generalangriff auf dem
produktiven industriellen kern und die
energieversorgung dieses landes sie
schauen dem niedergang der automobil und
zulieferindustrie
sogar mit genugtuung zu und vergeuden
steuergeld für grün linke
identitätspolitik wo sie jobs auf kosten
der allgemeinheit für ihre lobby gruppen
schaffen und die innere sicherheit
erodiert vor eskalierender messer gewalt
rohheitsdelikten und der wachsenden
unsicherheit auf den straßen
verschließen sie die augen dafür
kriminalisieren sie umso mehr mit
größeren eifer
regierungskritische proteste während
rechtstreuen bürger ohne digitalen ins
pascal restaurant betreten dürfen
bleiben die grenzen offen für illegale
einwanderer auch ohne ausweisdokumente
das ist eine unhaltbare völlig
rechtswidrige politik die diese
regierung verschlimmert und verstetigt
und der bundeskanzler scholz ihre
regierung
hat bereits in den ersten tagen über
deutlich gemacht wohin die reise mit
dieser koalition gehen soll es ist eine
geisterfahrt
korrigieren sie diesen kurs sorgen sie
für die einhaltung des rechts die
wiederherstellung der gerechtigkeit
einen sie dieses land statt es weiter zu
spalten ich bedanke mich
vielen dank frau kollegin
doch es war die zweite von der afc die
ampel startete mit unseriösen
verfassungsrechtlichen
tricksereien beim haushalt heftig
kritisierte weil die fdp aber auch olaf
scholz der die gesellschaft spalte die
europapolitik gerücht berücksichtige
nicht die nationalen interessen die
ampel habe keine antworten auf inflation
die energieversorgung sei nicht
gesichert nächster redner nun christian
dürr der neue fraktionsvorsitzende der
fdp vielen dank herr präsident meine
sehr verehrten kollegen kollegen herr
bundeskanzler
sie haben das eingangs ihrer rede gesagt
die korona pandemie hält unser land nach
wie vor in atem wir sind in einer
vierten welle aber anders als vor einem
jahr reden wir in deutschland zurzeit
nicht über eine flächendeckende
schließung des einzelhandels anders als
vor einem jahr haben in deutschland
derzeit keine nächtlichen
ausgangssperren anders als vor einem
jahr haben wir glücklicherweise in
deutschland keine flächendeckenden
schulschließung wir haben seit einigen
tagen in deutschland die erfolgreichste
booster kampagne in der europäischen
union in diesen tagen wird in
deutschland so viel geimpft wie noch nie
seit zu beginn der impfkampagne meine
damen und herren es waren letzte woche
6,4 millionen dosen in der woche die
impfbereitschaft der menschen in
deutschland da will ich einfach mal
danke für sagen die ins bereitschaft der
menschen in deutschland ist da und
deswegen auch das sage ich zu anfang
meiner rede bin ich dem
bundesgesundheitsminister dankbar dass
er sich jetzt explizit darum kümmern
wird dass das nicht abreißt es darf
nicht passieren dass die impfstoff
beschaffung jetzt nicht eingehalten
werden kann meine
und da muss man auch mit verlaub herr
brinkhaus ich bin nach ihrer rede teilen
etwas überrascht etwas selbstkritisch
mit der eigenen regierungsarbeit umgehen
was die in stoff beschaffung betrifft
haben wir das heute bedauerlicherweise
den tageszeitungen entnehmen müssen aber
sie haben ja auch ganz viel gesprochen
diese koalition hat bereits vor
regierungsbeginn doch in wahrheit
gezeigt was ein anderer stil ist auch
wie man miteinander umgeht und ich fand
das spannend dass sie herr brinkhaus zu
beginn ihrer rede gesagt haben wir
wollen keine beleidigte opposition sein
und sie sprechen den bundeskanzler
scholz respekt aus das freut uns aber
der allererste punkt ihrer rede herr
brinkhaus ist die sitzordnung im
deutschen bundestag für mich jedenfalls
klingt das beleidigt ich glaube sie
sollten an der stelle noch an sich
arbeiten lieber kollege bringt
und es wird jetzt sofort die ärmel hoch
gekämpft denn es geht in den kommenden
wochen und monaten bereits um ganz ganz
wichtige entscheidungen in deutschland
es geht um die frage ob wir schaffen
deutschland gerade nach dieser chor und
wirtschaft corinna wirtschaftskrise auch
auf einen wachstumspfad zurückzubringen
dabei geht es ja nicht um irgendwelche
volkswirtschaftlichen statistiken
sondern es geht um die frage von
lebenschancen und lebensträume von
menschen in unserem land deswegen hat
sich diese koalition sehr klar auf die
fahnen geschrieben dass es keine
steuererhöhungen geben wird damit
menschen in deutschland nicht stärker
belastet werden meine damen und herren
deswegen
hat sich auch
damit wir in zukunft nicht mehr belasten
müssen diese koalition auf die fahnen
geschrieben dass wir finanzielle
solidität walten lassen und an der
grundgesetzlichen schuldenbremse
festhalten auch an der stelle will ich
eine sache in richtung der heutigen
oppositionspartei union sagen auch weil
sie es in ihrer rede erwähnt haben der
brinkhaus mit verlaub sie sind die
schwarze stichwortgeber es war der
heutige kandidat für den cdu
bundesvorsitz helge braun der die
schuldenbremse schleifen wollte es war
mit verlaub im bundestagswahlkampf amila
stadt und insbesondere markus söder
wollte die schuldenbremse im grundgesetz
ändern meine damen und herren die union
ist der falsche ratgeber auch für uns an
dieser stelle
wir werden damit wir die wirtschaftliche
dynamik die die lebensträume erst
verwirklichen lässt damit diese
wirtschaftliche dynamik wieder in gang
kommt werden die die wachstumspotenziale
unseres landes stärken müssen dabei
werden wir der bundeskanzler hat es
gesagt planungs beschleunigung bereits
unsere nachbarländer in der europäischen
union sind teilweise doppelt so schnell
deswegen ist es ein richtiges ziel
dieser regierung dass wir die
planungszeiten in deutschland halbieren
meine damen und herren seien ganz
wichtiges signal an unternehmern und an
gründer in deutschland die einen traum
verwirklichen wollen und arbeitsplätze
für unser land schaffen wollen meine
damen und herren wir
werden super abschreibung einführen
damit jetzt gerade während dieser krise
noch investiert wird in deutschland
damit wir in zukunft in wohlstand leben
und arbeitsplätze schaffen meine damen
und herren und ein ganz ganz wichtiges
ziel auch für den deutschen mittelstand
ein ganz wichtiges ziel gerade weil die
energiekosten in den letzten jahren
gestiegen sind ein wichtiges ziel dieser
regierungskoalition ist dass wir ab dem
jahr 2023 die eeg-umlage abschaffen
werden meine damen und herren das
schafft wachstum und wohlstand für
deutschland liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das
ziel sind zuallererst mehr private
investitionen das haben sie
richtigerweise gesagt herr bundeskanzler
damit das gelingt und auch die
öffentlichen investitionen
beispielsweise in die infrastruktur
finanziert werden können hat die
bundesregierung einen nachtragshaushalt
dem bundestag zugeleitet da wird da
werden bereits bewilligte
kreditermächtigung in den zukünftigen
klima und transformations- form
überführt und dann das ziel ist ja ganz
klar das ziel ist die schnelle
beseitigung der haushaltsnotlage in
deutschland ich habe über solidität von
besprochen das ziel muss sein dass wir
ab 2023 nicht mehr den notfall
mechanismus der schuldenbremse ziehen
müssen meine damen und herren und
deswegen werden wir mit diesem
nachtragshaushalt gerade keine neuen
schulden machen und ich habe mich
besonders gewundert über die
angekündigte normenkontrollklage der cdu
csu fraktion an der stelle denn anders
als die ampel koalition in diesem
nachtragshaushalt lieber herr kollege
brinkhaus haben sie mit ihrer stimme im
jahr 2020 einem nachtragshaushalt
zugestimmt der zusätzliche schulden
gemacht hat um dann in ein
sondervermögen überführt wenn sie jetzt
gegen diese regierung klagen wollen
müssen wir zuallererst gegen sich selbst
lernen herrn brinkhaus der volksmund
nennt so etwas heute leid und das auch
mit verlaub zu sagen
und ich
habe über zukunftschancen vorhin
gesprochen besonders gelitten in den
letzten 16 jahren einer unionsgeführten
bundesregierung meine dort meine damen
und herren hat doch in wahrheit das
aufstiegsversprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft
chancen gerade junger menschen hängen in
deutschland zu sehr von der herkunft zu
sehr vom elternhaus ab deswegen haben
wir uns vorgenommen massiv in bildung zu
investieren
4000 schulen mit einem hohen anteil
sozial
benachteiligter kinder werden wir
besonders fördern wir werden einen
digital pack 2.0 auf den weg bringen wir
werden das bafög in deutschland endlich
eltern unabhängiger machen und meine
damen und herren dazu gehört natürlich
auch bezahlbares wohnen
selbstverständlich das gelingt aber nur
wenn in deutschland schneller und mehr
wohnungen gebaut werden der bisherige
innenminister von von der csu herr
seehofer der dafür zuständig war er hat
verdammt viele wohnen gibt für gemacht
aber es wurden verdammt wenig wohnung in
deutschland gebaut diese koalition wird
es genau umgekehrt machen meine damen
und herren um das aufstiegsversprechen
zu gewährleisten
und wir werden die menschen dabei
entlasten die eeg-umlage ich erwähnte es
für die unternehmen in deutschland das
gilt natürlich ganz genau so für die
privaten haushalte
wir werden eine vollständige
abzugsfähigkeit der rentenbeiträge
bereits ab dem jahr 2023 durchsetzen das
ist eine ente
und den ausbildungsfreibetrag
lebe heute zu entschuldigen solange wir
keine stabile leitung haben schalte ich
noch mal zu meiner kollegin ines trams
die ja wie schon am anfang sagte vom
bundestag aus von der seite aus die
debatte beobachtet ihn ist die ist das
einzuschätzen wie ist die
regierungserklärung von olaf scholz zu
bewerten er hat ja viele es sie war
ausgesprochen lang ungewöhnlich lang
sehr kleinteilig die cdu hat ihm
vorgeworfen ist fehlen die großen linien
und ich fand es erstaunlich dass zum
beispiel die außenpolitik sehr kurz
behandelt wurde und erst relativ spät
kam also wie ist die regierungserklärung
seine erste insgesamt zu bewirken
ich denke man muss die zweigeteilte
anschauen zum einen sieht man zu beginn
höre mich jetzt hier gerade doppelt so
jetzt gehts besser also zu beginn der
regierungserklärung haben wir einen olaf
scholz erlebt in der neuen rolle
gefühlvoll und nahbar das kennen wir von
olaf scholz so bislang nicht aber
kämpferisch zugleich äußerte mehrfach
verständnis für die bürger die genug
haben von pandemie bedingten
einschränkungen er äußerte verständnis
für bürger die ja angst haben vor den
veränderungen vor denen diese
gesellschaft steht auf der anderen seite
zeigte er sich aber eben auch
kämpferisch so kündigte er
gewaltbereiten corona leugnern den kampf
an beteuerte wir sind eine wehrhafte
demokratie und er sagte generell mit
blick auf die pandemie wir werden diese
krise überwinden wir werden diesen kampf
gewinnen später im zweiten teil erlebten
wir einen olaf scholz wie wir ihn in den
vergangenen jahren immer wieder erlebt
haben er ja er wäre zitierte kapitel für
kapitel punkt für punkt aus dem
koalitionsvertrag das war dann doch eher
wieder der scholzomat scholz den wir
bislang gesehen hatten ja herzlichen
dank bis hierher ich höre die leitung
steht wieder und wir gehen wieder zurück
ins plenum zur rede des fdp
fraktionsvorsitzenden dr
ich könnte die liste unendlich
fortsetzen sie alle suchen händeringend
kluge köpfe und fleißige hände die
konservativen haben hier seit vielen
jahren eine moderne und eine
unideologische einwanderungspolitik
verhindert diesen historischen fehler
werden wir korrigieren die ampel hat
sich zum herzensanliegen gemacht dass
deutschland endlich platz nimmt in der
mitte der länder in der welt hier ein
einwanderungsland mutter natur sein
wollen meine damen und herren wir wollen
ein modernes einwanderungsland werden
das ist die botschaft der ampelkoalition
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und zum schluss
herr präsident
steht als titel auf dem
koalitionsvertrag wir wollen mehr
fortschritt waren ich habe über
demografie eben gesprochen wir werden
beispielsweise den einstieg in eine
aktien renten schaffen wir wollen
dekarbonisierung bis 2045 klimaneutral
sein dazu brauchen wir
technologieoffenheit den europäischen
emissionshandel haben sie erwähnt und
wir wollen ein digitalisiertes
deutschland ein unkompliziertes staat in
dem das soziale auf schießt versprechen
endlich wieder geht ich danke ihnen
vielen dank herr kollege hören das war
der neue fdp fraktionsvorsitzende
christian doerr der natürlich den start
der ampel regierung lobte das
miteinander sei anders besser als zuvor
beim gipfel gehe es voran er betonte
erneut dass es keine steuererhöhungen
geben werde kein aufweichen der
schuldenbremse wie die fdp es im
wahlkampf versprochen haben es folgt nun
die fraktionsvorsitzende der linken am
ihrer mohammed ali
[Applaus]
särge der präsident kolleginnen und
kollegen herr scholz in ihrer rede
fanden sie wieder worte des dankes für
die pflegerinnen und pfleger auch
ankündigungen hat man wieder gehört dass
kennen die pflegerinnen und pfleger
bereits zu genüge noch aus ihrer zeit
als vizekanzler
ankündigungen reichen nicht aus
sie haben ein pflege bonus versprochen
er soll erst im nächsten jahr kommen
dabei haben wir letzte woche hier
beantragt dass er sofort kommen soll und
zwar für alle sie haben es abgelehnt
außer der linken hat keine fraktion in
diesem hause unserem antrag zugestimmt
und ich muss sagen ich finde es
unglaublich und
die begründung die begründung ist sie
bräuchten noch zeit um genau zu klären
wer den pflege bonus bekommen soll und
wer eben nicht mit anderen worten sie
wollen gerade nicht alle pflegerinnen
und pfleger bedenken und da frage ich
sie warum denn nicht wir wissen doch
dass im gesundheitswesen im gesamten
gesundheitswesen die pflegerinnen und
pfleger seit jahren an der
belastungsgrenze arbeiten
wir können sie nicht einfach mal sagen
alle bekommen wir also wissen sie diese
aufmerksamkeit dieser genauigkeit die
wünsche ich mir in zukunft mal wenn es
darum geht steuerschlupflöcher für
großkonzerne herr multi millionäre zu
stopfen oder wenn es darum geht
korruptionsskandale in der politik
aufzudecken
sein kollege du kollegen im
gesundheitsbereich muss sich wirklich
grundlegend etwas ändern es ist links
zeit zu klopfen und nicht immer nur zu
kleckern herr scholz aktuell
für nochmal und 4000 intensivbetten
weniger betreut werden als anfang des
jahres und warum weil noch mehr
pflegerinnen und pfleger ausgebrannt und
ernüchtert ihren beruf an den nagel
gehängt haben sie halten diese zustände
einfach nicht mehr aus pflegerinnen und
pfleger müssen doch jetzt aktiv für den
beruf zurück gewonnen werden unser
konkreter vorschlag lautet zehn tagen
euro prämie für alle die zurückkehren
und auch für alle die geblieben sind
sinnvolle maßnahme sollten sie umsetzen
außerdem muss das gesundheitssystem
insgesamt endlich wieder vom kopf auf
die füße gestellt werden das heißt allen
voran schluss mit dem zerstörerischen
fallpauschalensystem denn was bedeutet
das konkret überall da wo jemand mehr
hilfe und behandlung braucht als der
durchschnitt müssen die mehrkosten an
anderer stelle wieder reingeholt werden
und ich kann es nicht anders sagen diese
logik dass ich im gesundheitswesen im
ergebnis alles rechnen muss die ist
einfach pervers und herr lauterbach
aber vorsicht da aber ihre medizinische
expertise in allen ehren aber sie haben
das damals mit eingeführt als die
damalige gesundheitsministerin ulla
schmidt beraten haben sie haben
mitgemacht dabei als unser
gesundheitssystem auf profit getrimmt
wurde jetzt ist die chance da lernt die
aus diesen fehlern im gesundheitssystem
darf es nur um eines gehen um die
gesundheit der menschen
spielen
mit dem forum management unzufrieden wir
erleben chaos schlechte kommunikation
was ist geplant herr scholz sie haben
gesagt unsere gesellschaft die ist nicht
gespalten das ist sie leider doch die
ist sozial gespalten das müssen sie doch
endlich mal sehen und das viele für den
letzten rest in vertrauen von vertrauen
in die politik verlieren müssen sie auch
sehen und damit meine ich ausdrücklich
nicht die korona leugne den boden der
realität vollkommen verlassen haben
angeführt von rechtsradikalen mit
fackeln durch die straßen laufen
menschen bedrohen das völlig
inakzeptabel hier ist jedes verständnis
fehl am platz
was ich meine ist der skandal wie viele
menschen nach wie vor im regen stehen
gelassen werden immer noch die
lehrerinnen und lehrer die schülerinnen
und schüler die rentnerin die es nicht
schafft einen boost akademie termin zu
ergattern weil sie kein internet hat er
sich heute impfen oder testen das möchte
steht tatsächlich vielerorts
buchstäblich im regen in den langen
schlangen vor den test und impfzentren
und das geht doch nicht ich meine auch
die gastronomie den einzelhandel die
kulturschaffenden sie müssen doch
endlich wissen ganz konkret wie es für
sie weitergehen soll hier braucht es
endlich sicherheit und
planungssicherheit auch hier ankündigung
blumige versprechen das können die leute
nicht mehr hören wir brauchen konkrete
lösungen erörtern
und sie braucht es auch für das problem
das seit geraumer zeit praktisch alles
teurer wird lebensmittel energie miete
ruft die löhne die steigen nicht
entsprechend und ihre antwort darauf ist
der höhere mindestlohn von 12 euro
höherer mindestlohn ist ja gut aber das
reicht doch nicht was sagen sie denn zum
beispiel der paketbote mit 13 euro
stundenlohn aber ohne tarifvertrag wir
wissen dass unsichere schlecht bezahlte
arbeit direkt in die altersarmut kühlt
sie werben mit stabilen renten ja gut
aber
dagegen dass vielen menschen in diesem
land die rente eben nicht zum leben
reicht dass sie viel zu niedrig und
viele die altersarmut droht dagegen tun
sie indem ich leider nicht es gibt kein
konzept gegen niedrige renten das geht
so nicht
auch ein mikro stoff ist nicht
vorgesehen und das erpresserische hartz4
system durch das die betroffenen seit
jahren an den rand der gesellschaft
gedrängt werden doch soll im ergebnis
bleiben es bekommt einen schöneren namen
aber diese charade die machen wir nicht
mit kolleginnen und kollegen mit dem er
die steigende energiekosten die sind für
immer mehr menschen ein ernsthaftes
problem das müssen sie doch bitte
endlich sehen was wir brauchen ist ein
sofortiger preisstopp der energiekosten
für verbraucher wollen verbraucher ich
bin sofort dabei wenn es heißt dass
konzerne wie viel energie verbrauchen
wenn die durch klare regelungen dazu
gezwungen werden ihren verbrauch zu
reduzieren das sehr sinnvoll aber ihre
energiepolitik führt dazu dass sich
immer mehr menschen ernsthafte sorgen
darüber machen müssen über die feiertage
in dunklen kalten wohnungen zu sitzen
das geht doch so nicht
und insgesamt geht es nicht dass das
normale leben immer teurer und teurer
wird eben besonders wenn die löhne nicht
entsprechend steigt und außerdem völlig
inakzeptabel ist dass das was alle drei
ampel parteien noch im wahlkampf
versprochen haben eben nicht kommen soll
nämlich das kleine und mittlere
einkommen endlich steuerlich entlastet
werden davon ist keine rede mehr und
liebe grüne lieber spd von ihren
wahlkampfversprechen dass endlich die
multi millionäre und milliardäre
steuerlich zur kasse gebeten werden
sollen auch davon hört man leider nichts
mehr
der schuld wenn ihre sogenannte gerechte
steuerpolitik ein buch wäre dann wäre es
ein buch mit leeren seiten aber mit
einem zufrieden lachenden christian lind
nach vorne drauf
zur außenpolitik
wie deutschland hier ergeht ist von
großer internationaler bedeutung wir
erleben momentan konflikte innerhalb
europas insbesondere der konflikt
zwischen russland und der ukraine macht
uns große sorgen doch statt mäßigen der
töne und bemühungen um verhandlungen
wird man aus ihrem außenministerium vor
allem verschärfen geteilt was unser land
außenpolitisch braucht ist aber eine
politik die wieder konsequent den dialog
und den spannung ist zentrum setzt eine
außenpolitik im sinne von willy brandt
nicht im geiste von joschka fischer
und wenn es ihnen mit der frage der
menschenrechte und der pressefreiheit
wirklich ernst ist dann zeigen sie das
bitte im fall des journalisten julien
sie wissen ihm droht die auslieferung
aus großbritannien in die usa wo ihr
eine lebenslange haft erwartet weil er
kriegsverbrechen des us militärs im irak
in afghanistan öffentlich gemacht
mitglieder ihre regierungen haben noch
vor kurzem ein appell unterzeichnet für
seine sofortige freilassung darum ich
fordere dass ich aufgeben sie den
assange politisches asyl in deutschland
das war die fraktionsvorsitzende der
linken amira mohammed ali vor allem die
verschiebung des pflege bonus für
pflegekräfte kritisierte für sie ist die
gesellschaft sozial gespalten zu
schlecht sei das corona management auch
die inflation zu hohe mieten hohe
energiekosten seien nach wie vor große
probleme
nächster redner nun rolf mützenich der
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin erleichtert
erleichtert und bei aller deutlichkeit
vielleicht auch lautstärke
unserer debatte dass offensichtlich ein
stil in unserer aussprache zurückkehrt
die unserer politischen kultur aber
unserem selbstverständnis auch in diesem
parlament angemessen ist attacke
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union ist richtig aber ich hab zu meiner
genugtuung festgestellt die stärkste
oppositionspartei im haus versprüht kein
antidemokratisches gift mehr mit dem uns
die afg hier jahrelang überzogen hat
streit ich habe gesagt ich habe gesagt
kein nein ich hab ich habe gesagt kein
antidemokratisches gift mehr in diesem
haus wie die af.de es getan hat und
dafür bin ich dankbar diese debatte
brauchen wir hier im deutschen bundestag
deswegen sage ich auch sehr class ja
streits gehört zur demokratie aber zum
streit gehört eben auch gehört eben auch
die demokratie und keine demokratie
vechta liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der hfg
und er bringt aus es mag sein dass sie
gerne doch auf diesem platz ein kanzler
von der union gesehen hätten aber die
menschen in diesem land wollten es
anders auf diesem platz sollte ein
sozialdemokrat platz nehmen und dafür
bin ich dankbar und wir werden dieses
vertrauen in den nächsten vier jahren
erfüllen meine damen und herren
und wie sie bringt aus biete ich auch
ihnen
kooperationen an und ich würde mich
freuen dass alles das was in den letzten
jahren von ihnen blockiert worden ist
vielleicht auch bei ihnen etwas
überprüft wird aber ich danke ihnen dass
sie insbesondere
in existenziellen fragen auf diese
debattenkultur die dieses parlament
braucht zurückkommen weil die menschen
beschäftigt in erster linie gerade auch
vor weihnachten und in den nächsten
monaten die pandemie weil es eine
existenzfrage ist nicht nur eine
existenzfrage für die demokratie für
dieses parlament sondern für jeden
einzelnen für familien für betriebe für
vereine und für die gesamte gesellschaft
überall in unserem land und deswegen
haben wir versucht diesen menschen so
gut wie möglich beizustehen wir haben
helfen errichtet wir haben arbeit
gesichert und wir haben auch die
rechtlichen möglichkeiten geschaffen und
deswegen sage ich auch sehr deutlich wir
wissen um die sorgen in dieser
gesellschaft aber wir wissen auch die
mehrheit der menschen stehen zu einem
kurs der eben auch sagt impfung ist der
beste schutz in dieser pandemie und
deswegen sage ich impfen impfen impfen
und nicht quertreiber weil es sinn
quertreiber keine querdenker die eben
die vernunft aus dieser gesellschaft
herausbekommen wollen wir wollen eine
vernünftige politik machen um diese
pandemie zurückzudrängen und dafür steht
diese koalition
und ja meine damen und herren wir haben
es schon vor einem jahr gemeinsam hier
befürchtet dass sich teile davon in
diesem land radikalisieren werden und es
ist eine schande eine schande für die
demokratie das mit fackelzügen vor
entscheidungsträgern vor die häuser
versucht wird zu kommen oder sogar davor
zu demonstrieren und es ist eine schande
dass die afd bei diesen demonstration
hilft dass sie sie lenkt und dass sie
diese logistik dafür bereitet so etwas
gehört meine damen und herren nicht ins
parlament
aber auf der anderen seite
ich will auch sehr deutlich sagen wir
wären keine volksvertretung wenn wir
nicht die nuancen in unserer
gesellschaft auch zur kenntnis nehmen
würden in meiner heimatstadt müssen sich
menschen rechtfertigen warum sie nicht
sich haben impfen lassen aber es gibt
immer noch regionen in deutschland wo
sich menschen fragen lassen müssen warum
hast du dich geimpft und genau das
müssen wir umkehren auch in einer
debatte hier im deutschen bundestag wenn
wir in den nächsten wochen über die
frage einer verbindlichen impfpflicht in
diesem land diskutieren und deswegen
sage ich sehr deutlich sage ich sehr
deutlich
diese debatte meine damen und herren
muss gewissenhaft
differenziert und offen geführt werden
weil auch in meiner fraktion gibt es
nicht die befürworter alle für die
allgemeine impfpflicht und es gibt eben
auch bei uns in meiner fraktion
kolleginnen und kollegen die das ein
oder andere bedenken vorbringen möchten
und das will ich auch ermöglichen dass
diese bedenken auch hier im deutschen
bundestag zu wort kommen werden ja das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns großen
spielraum eingeräumt bei der
möglicherweise allgemeine impfpflicht in
diesem land aber dennoch es ist ein
eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit und deswegen brauchen wie
eine grundsatzdebatte in diesem haus und
ich sage für meine fraktion wir wollen
die ermöglichen
und umso mehr
muss bis zu dieser debatte sehr klar
geklärt werden ob der staat alle
umfassenden maßnahmen ergriffen hat
damit sich eben auch alle menschen
impfen lassen können und wenn wir heute
davon erfahren dass zu wenig impfstoff
im lande doch da ist sowohl für die
erste für die zweite aber auch für die
booster impfung dann muss hier
nachgearbeitet werden wenn dieser
impfstoff nicht vorhanden ist können wir
auch nicht verantwortungsvoll diese
debatte führen und wenn wir nicht
niedrigschwellig niedrigschwellige
angebote vorhalten oder auch die
aufklärung für alle menschen die in
unserem land leben so gewährleisten dass
sie sich impfen lassen wollen dann
gehört zu dieser differenzierten debatte
genau diese fragen dazu umso wichtiger
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und das
dank nicht der bundesregierung die dies
bereits im übergang auch auf den weg
gebracht hat dass ein expertenrat jetzt
gegründet worden ist und der auch schon
getagt hat und diese expertenrat ist
pluralistisch angelegt das kann
vertrauen in diesem land schaffen weil
es eben auch in der wissenschaft
unterschiedliche meinungen zu diesen
fragen gegeben hat und genau das ist
auch die voraussetzung um vertrauen in
den nächsten monaten zu schaffen
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass es
gelingt noch mehr menschen vom impfen zu
überzeugen mit diesen maßnahmen die in
den letzten wochen auf den weg gebracht
worden sind meine damen und herren ja
die pandemie ist eine große belastung
aber bereits ohne pandemie werden die
herausforderung für eine künftige
bundesregierung
riesengroß und umfassend der
bundeskanzler hat hier wie andere
rednerinnen und rednern auch davon
gesprochen dass diese zwanziger jahre
dieses jahrhunderts
der anfang einer großen neuen
transformation sind ja und diese
transformation ist nicht etwas ganz
neues in der deutschen oder europäischen
geschichte aber diese transformation
wird rasanter und letztlich auch
bahnbrechender sein als viele
transformationen zuvor und wenn sie
rasanter ist ist auch die
herausforderung für die gesellschaft für
die menschen letztlich so groß der weg
zur fossilen
industriegesellschaft hat über 100 jahre
gedauert und wir sind sicher dass dieser
rasante bahnbrechende weg in dieser
transformation innerhalb von wenigen
jahrzehnten geschafft werden muss sonst
erfüllen wir nicht die ziele die wir uns
auch in diesem koalitionsvertrag gegeben
haben und deswegen muss auf der einen
seite natürlich eben das stehen was wir
uns im koalitionsvertrag vorgenommen
haben aber auf der anderen seite eben
auch letztlich die maßnahmen ein zu
ziehen die den menschen halt geben in
einer bahnbrechenden transformation die
jeden erreichen wird und das sind meine
damen und herren
schutzgesetze auf der einen seite
innovation fördern aber eben auch die
kunst zu haben frühzeitig neue ideen für
diesen weg auch zu ecken und diese neuen
ideen liegen vielleicht zurzeit in den
laboren liegen vielleicht in den köpfen
von wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern aber wir haben diese
aufgabe diese ideen zu fördern und dann
auch in diese transformation
einzubringen meine damen und herren und
die großen chancen die sich daraus
ergeben sind offensichtlich es kann gute
arbeit bedeutend gute arbeit wenn wir
insbesondere auf der einen seite mit
unternehmerinnen und unternehmern aber
auf der anderen seite mit den
gewerkschaften mit den arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmern zusammenarbeiten aber
der kern in dieser frage und das ist
glaube ich der unterschied zu den
früheren transformationen wir haben
heute das wissen die erfahrung und die
fähigkeiten diese transformation zu
gestalten und nicht zu getriebenen zu
werden wir wollen das heft des handelns
in der hand behalten und ich bin sicher
dass kann diese fortschritts koalition
meine damen und herren und genau das ist
auch die große chance für die nächsten
vier jahren
fortschritt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wagen wir in dieser koalition
gemeinsam auf augenhöhe und trotzdem
biete ich an
206 talente in meiner fraktion davon 104
die in den neuen deutschen bundestag
eingezogen sind und deswegen werden
diese kolleginnen und kollegen in meiner
fraktion genau darauf achten ob kluge
investitionen vorangetrieben werden ob
die erneuerbare energie eben auch so
ausgebaut wird dass wir auf sie setzen
können wie wir in zukunft netze ausbauen
können die verkehre erweitern forschung
ermöglichen uns das ist die große
herausforderung es muss mehr sein als
nur ein haushaltsjahr nämlich wir
investieren in die zukunft meine damen
und herren
und ja
die aufgabe meiner fraktion wird
insbesondere seien gleichzeitig das
augenmerk auf diejenigen zu lenken die
zu wenig oder gar keine lobby arm um es
mit anderen worten zu sagen die es
schwer haben sich im leben durchzusetzen
und deswegen sind gerade die frage von
respekt im wahlkampf so wichtig gewesen
dass wir sie auch in die konkrete
regierungsarbeit überführen gute arbeit
qualifizierung und weiterbildung der
mindestlohn ausbildungsplatzgarantie
eine reform des bafögs und vieles andere
das müssen die leitplanken einer politik
sein um die menschen auch in dieser
großen transformation meine damen und
herren mitnehmen zu können auf der
anderen seite
wir schauen heute auf uns natürlich und
das haben wir auch in den letzten tagen
getan aber vieles um uns herum
schafft große sorgen und ich sage sehr
deutlich diese transformation
die die menschen mit ihren eigenen
fähigkeiten in ihrer hand nehmen können
ist darauf angewiesen dass in europa
frieden herrscht und deswegen müssen wir
auch über unsere eigenen grenzen hinaus
schauen über das was hier dieses
parlament ausmacht und deswegen meine
damen und herren muss ich sagen ich bin
erschrocken wenn in dieser pandemie die
weltweite wirtschaftsleistung
zurückgegangen ist aber die
rüstungsindustrie die größten gewinne in
diesen jahren eingefahren hat das ist
ein menetekel und das muss
zurückgedrängt werden deswegen sage ich
friedenspolitik ist notwendig ist
notwendig damit transformationen aber
auch die links und deswegen bin ich auch
nicht der meinung wie einige
kommentatoren die da sagen der kalte
krieg ist zurückgekehrt das problem in
unseren köpfen bei einigen zumindestens
ist dass die reflexe des kalten krieges
zurückgekehrt sind und deswegen muss
dieser teufelskreis aus durchbrochen
wird ja
demokratien untereinander können am
besten frieden halten und demokratien
können auch am besten frieden stiften im
innern wie im äußern und gerade in einer
welt die sich offensichtlich nicht mehr
an regeln und das völkerrecht hält
müssen wir auch die verantwortlichen
benennen und ja es besteht doch gar kein
zweifel dass russland die regeln und das
völkerrecht gebrochen hat das mit der
völkerrechtswidrigen besetzung der krim
ein spaltpilz auch wieder nach europa
zurück gekommen ist und deswegen kann
auch russland nicht die bedingungen für
die freien länder in europa diktieren
weil das würde unterordnung kreisen aber
der unterschied ist meine damen und
herren
demokratien sind in der lage und
deswegen haben sie die freiheit auch
kluge antworten auf diese
herausforderung zu geben und der
brinkhaus dann würde ich sie gerne
vielleicht daran erinnern dass zumindest
in den 90er jahren einmal ein
verteidigungsminister von ihrer partei
volker rühe gesagt hat dass staaten eben
nur einen bündnis beitreten können wenn
sie keine ungelösten konflikte in dieses
bündnis hinein tragen wenn sie
demokratie und marktwirtschaft achten
und wenn sie auch die freiheit im
inneren achten und deswegen kann ich
auch nur sagen die in rede stehenden
länder tun dies zurzeit nicht und
deswegen sind kluge antworten auch
gefragt auf diese herausforderung
nämlich wir können und das ist der
unterschied der brinkhaus zwischen ihnen
und mir konflikt stoff aus der debatte
heraus nimmt das habe ich gelernt von
einer sozialdemokratischen
klugen außenpolitik die nämlich auf der
einen seite gesagt hat grenzen müssen
wir setzen aber auf der anderen seite
auch auswege aufzeigen das ist genau
eine politik die ich mir wünsche und
lass meine damen und herren hat in der
vergangenen woche vielleicht zu ihrer
überraschung der amerikanische und der
russische präsident getan weil sie
wollen nämlich über eine europäische
sicherheits ordnung unter einschluss von
nato-ländern nachdenken und deswegen
glaube ich ist es richtig diesen weg
auch mit aller deutlichkeit zu gehen
unsere koalition hat eine große
verantwortung für unser land und für
europa durch vernunft konzentration und
überzeugung wollen wir helfen gutes zu
schaffen meine damen und herren dafür
lohnt es sich zu arbeiten vielen dank
so wir blenden uns an dieser stelle aus
der debatte aus der ersten
regierungserklärung von olaf scholz zum
abschluss schalten wir aber noch einmal
zu meiner kollegin ines trams im
bundestag ging es wie ist denn die
heutige debatte zu bewerten war da viel
von fortschritt von einem neuen
umgangston miteinander zu spüren und wie
ist die regierungserklärung zu bewerten
die ja sehr nach innen gerichtet war das
thema außenpolitik kam erst ganz am ende
ganz genau ich denke es war eine sehr
nach innen gerichtete rede von kanzler
scholz mehrfach hob er ab auf den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt ohne den
so sagte er die veränderungen die
anstünden schlicht nicht zu schaffen
sein wie schon im wahlkampf forderte er
mehr respekt füreinander zu zeigen
erforderte wenn man so will mehr
augenhöhe innerhalb der gesellschaft
weniger herablassung
auf die außenpolitik kam tatsächlich wie
du es erwähnt hast erst zu sprechen nach
einer stunde 15 seinen fokus hatte er da
vor allem auf europa das verhältnis
deutschlands zu beispielsweise russland
oder china streift er eigentlich nur und
insofern bleibt es nach wie vor unklar
was für eine außenpolitik wir von dieser
ampel regierung zu erwarten haben wird
es eine außenpolitik sein die vor allem
werte im blick hat oder die vor allem
die export nation deutschland im blick
hat ja genau darüber gab es ja die
diskussion ist außenpolitik chefsache
oder nicht das wird dann vielleicht
thema der nächsten debatte sein die
heutige weitere debatte können sie bei
phoenix verfolgen es folgt ihr jetzt im
hauptprogramm die 12 uhr heute sendung
aus mainz ich bedanke mich für ihr
interesse wünschen noch einen schönen
tag und sage tschüss bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]